hello and welcome to this first virtual
meeting of the annual Council first
mayor I remind you all of some domestic
arrangements please ensure that your
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking please ensure that you do not
interrupt other speakers members are
reminded not to use the messaging chat
chat function during the meeting unless
it is to report a pecuniary
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair that you wish to make a proposal
and if you are leaving the council
meeting that if you are attending the
meeting to speak persistently interrupt
the meeting you may be asked to speak
asked to
leave additionally you'll be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair
please await your turn if members lose
connection to the meeting they must
contact the member Support Officer Mandy
Smith ASAP and as this is a virtual
meeting you do not need to stand to
address the
chair I would like to remind everyone
present this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewing the whole of the me
meeting will be filmed except for
whether there are confidential or exempt
items if you make representation to the
meeting you'll have deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you also
consented to being filmed by the council
and possible uses of these images and
sound recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the Press May film record
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded can I move to the
agenda please agenda item one election
of the chairman of the
council please can I have nominations
for the position of chair of the
council chair I'd like to make a
nomination
please
okay do I you know you can
continue e um thank you very much chair
um I'd like to propose um councelor
Penny uton as chair of the council um
Council roton has been a district
councelor for 29 years she is a valued
member of both the council and her
community we used to have a tradition at
mids suffk of um the chairs being
long-standing counselors regardless of
of political persuasion as befits a
non-political role um many of the
previous chairs have were particularly
long-standing um counselors such as
councelor Melvin and councelor Barker
more recently this tradition seems to
have fallen away and I think it would be
a shame it's been a shame that this has
happened and I think it'd be good to get
back to
it to vote in as chair
um long-standing counselors who have the
experience and gravitus that this role
requires would be really beneficial to
the council councilor Ron would be an
excellent chair as someone with great
experience of the council in all its
roles and I commend her to you and ask
for a seconder thank you
chair do we have a
seconder I'm happy to second that thank
you would you like to say a few words um
councelor field just just a few to keep
it brief U and not to embarrass Council
a too much I guess uh um Rachel eburn
has covered most of the points of
significance and Council Aon has
certainly been with the council for a
long time and to my knowledge has
demonstrated those skills that are
absolutely necessary to maintain U
meetings of this type to run efficiently
and democratically and therefore I
believe will be an excellent choice for
this
position thank you are there any further
nominations yes
chair councilor Moy here the role of the
chairman is of course a great honor as
it is the Civic face of our Council
is a key role of our chairman is to Ste
us steer us skillfully and even handedly
through four Council meetings
recognizing and respecting the tied
political balance that we have in the
council chamber whilst also exercising
their judgment and casting vote when
required as we've debated many times
there is much that the conservative and
independent group agrees with with the
new agrees on with the newly formed
green and liberal Democrat
Alliance there are also however
significant issues and matters of
political philosophy where we do
not it is for this reason that it was
not possible to form a coalition cabinet
following the elections in May and for
the same reason that the conservative
and independent group formed the
administration whilst I fully respect
the capabilities of councilors councelor
uton from the opposition group to be our
chairman we firmly believe that it would
not be in the best interests of the
council mids Sauk or our residents to
create a a scenario where the
conservative and independent groups
aspirations and objectives which have
already been agreed by council could be
thwarted by the casting vote of the
chairman of the
council as the opposition group are also
well aware this would also in effect
mean the conservative and independent
group surrendering the leadership and
administration of the council to the
green and liberal Democrat Group which
is clearly something that no politician
of any color is ever going to willingly
do it is also more important than ever
with the challenges that the council and
our communities face as a result of
covid-19 that we are able to provide
consistent and stable
leadership I therefore have no
hesitation in nominating Council
humphris to be chair of mids District
Council and would call upon a seconder
thank you chair thank
you uh I would like to second please
councilor hadingham if I may absolutely
thank you um I'm delighted to Second
councelor Barry Humphrey's
MBE uh he has had the most distinguished
career and one in which we should all be
proud of that he is a counselor amongst
us 36 years in the regular army and now
a leftenant colonel in the Army
Reserves I must say uh as I've known
Barry over several years now he's shown
absolute skill in managing meetings and
running in a disciplined and ordered
manner so I know he will be the absolute
perfect person to chair our meetings in
the coming year he's been the town mayor
of Stow Market a town in which he shows
great pride and always just remind us
reminds us that Stow Market is the
center of the universe um he's a man
with great integrity and I can think no
one better and I'm delighted to Second
councelor Barry Humphries to be chairman
of the council thank you
um um the corporate manager governance
and Civic office will now take a roll
call
[Music]
vote thank you chair if councilors could
reply with the councilor's name that you
are voting
for councelor Amar
morison
what be voting
councelor you're voting on The
nominations so we have two nominations
one for councelor uton one for councelor
humph if you could call out the name of
the councelor you are voting for
please
uton councelor Brewster councelor humph
councelor
burn councelor Humphries councelor
Carter councelor auton councelor Caston
councelor Humphrey councel
eburn councelor uton councelor
epong councelor humre councelor
field councelor utton councelor flatman
councelor bar Barry humph councelor
Fleming councelor humph councelor geek
councelor uton councelor gold councelor
humre councelor
[Music]
goth sorry councelor H Barry Humphries
councelor hadingham
councelor Humphries councelor Hicks
councelor Humphries councelor humph
councelor humph councelor
Mansel councelor uton councelor Matson
councelor uton councelor
melon councelor uton councelor mayor
councelor humph councelor moley councel
humph councelor Müller councelor humph
councelor Norris councelor uton
councelor
uton myself councelor uton councelor
parore councelor Barry Humphries
councelor Phillips councelor utton
councelor Pratt councelor Aon councelor
Richardson councelor Humphries councelor
scar
councelor uton councelor Stringer
councelor uton councelor Turner
councelor uton councelor War boys
councelor peny utton councelor wellam
councelor utton councelor Whitehead
councelor Barry
Humphries thank you I just add the
[Music]
votes the Voting is
1717 can I ask the chair if she wishes
to exercise her Casting vote I would
like to and I will Vote councelor Barry
Humphries thank you
chair that means that councelor
Humphrey's um vote is
carried I declare councelor Barry
Humphrey is duly
elected and I now um call upon um um
councelor humph to um to to sign his
Declaration of acceptance and to um and
to um declare his um and to declare the
acceptance
speech Co hington thank you very much I
Barry Humphries having been elected to
the office of chairman of the council
hereby declare that I take the office
that office upon myself and will duy and
Faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability I undertake to be guided by the
local code of conduct in the performance
of my functions in that office and I
will sign this um straight
away thank you
is Julie
signed I do have a short speech and I
think it'd be wrong for me not to to
make one um so I'm really delighted to
accept the position of chair of midu
District Council and I do really thank
the proposer and a seconder for the kind
words um I'd also like to thank all of
you really for demonstrating your
support and your confidence in me as we
go forward throughout the year um this
will not be a one-man show and I will be
leaning heavily on the assistance of our
incredible team of officers including my
Civic officer and of course my vice
chair yet to be elected and I look
forward to working with you all uh one
should never forget the reason we became
counselors it was and is to serve and
represent our
communities irrespec of political
persuasion or all or Alliance without
fear or favor as a chair of this Council
I will strive to uphold that statement
and to be fair and open-minded as was my
predecessor councelor
haddington I'm sure I'm not alone in
wanting to thank councelor hadingham for
her service as the chair of midet
District Council in that post she has
represented the council at many meetings
and events across suffk and with her
infectious smile and positive attitude
impressed all that she met and this in
turn has left a positive and
far-reaching image of mid suffk and this
Council as a whole and we thank her uh
immensely for that even though these
have been difficult times she's done
Sterling work in raising much needed
funds and importantly the awareness of a
chosen charity home start mid suffk for
which I know they are very
grateful I've observed her closely as
Vice chair and I've learn a great deal
from her and I'm sure that this will
assist me both tonight and into the
future but I'd like you to join me in
thanking her so levinia thank you for
your service for the previous year it's
it's been exceptional thank
you she did demonstrate to me
demonstrate to me that the most
important or one of the most important
aspects of being chair are honesty
fairness and open-mindedness and when
necessary of course firmness and I won't
be shy in doing that uh there are
attributes um really that I admiring
anybody and I'll certainly be carrying
them forward as I go on as the chair I
do however expect politeness mutual
respect and good manners during meetings
and irres of your political views please
remember that every one of us is here to
do the very best we we can for Mid suffk
and all of its residents and although we
W always agree we are a good team and
share a common goal of serving the
residents of mid suffk to the very best
of our
abilities my chosen charity for this
year is the Stow Market dementia Action
Group which have already done great
things in making Stow market and The
Wider Community uh uh developing into a
robust dementia friendly Community I'll
do my very best to come up with
innovative ways in which to raise funds
for them but of course these are
difficult times so I will be relying on
you to assist me in that aim I look
forward to serving you as the chair once
again thank you for your confidence in
me uh now I'm with the meeting but
please be gentle it's my first time
okay just adjust my papers and uh I'll
come back to
you so Moving Straight on then to uh
item number two which is the election of
the vice chairman of the council uh May
H may I have the nominations for the
vice chair I'd like to nominate please C
John maton I'd like to
nominate thank you and who are you going
to nominate I'd like to nominate
councelor Roland War
booys thank you uh counselor do you have
any um anything to
say yes Council of War boys has although
having been with Us only for one term
has a a tremendous track record
particularly in the field of
Education across uh suffk and um I think
that he would bring great distinction to
the role of Vice chair thank
you thank you and do we'd have a second
uh yes uh uh thank you chair uh Council
Manel I'm happy to Second uh councilor
matson's proposal um I too think that
Council War boys would make a uh an
excellent Vice chair uh he's very
distinguished member of the community um
and uh yeah he he'd be he'd make a great
Vice chairman thank you councilor Manel
thank you very much are there any
further nominations yes I'd like to
nominate councelor Paul epong please
chair thank you councelor Miller and you
may make your short speech thank you
very much I've had the privilege of
working with councelor epong both on
mids District Council and Market Town
Council for The Last 5 Years I feel that
the experience that councelor epen Yong
has has built up um in private business
has been of great assistance to both
councils he's a man of the highest
integrity and he's the current mayor of
Stow market and I thoroughly recommend
him for the role of Vice chair thank you
chair thank you do we have a second
there um yes um it's councelor hadingham
here I'm happy to Second um councelor
epong as the vice um as the vice chair
I've known um I've known Council epong
since um we were both elected together
in 2015 and he's a well respected and
reliable and um and very um hardworking
and conscientious man like um like
councelor Miller said he has been the um
the mayor of Stone Market and um and
I've met him at several Civic um duties
and it was always a pleasure to see him
a friendly face and um and I thoroughly
recommend him to the rest to the council
thank you cing thank you very much um so
we have two nominees which is councilor
War boys and councelor EP penong um the
corporate manager of governance and the
Civic officer will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair um members please
can you reply with which counselor you
are voting for councelor Amar am
Morrison War
boys councelor Brewster councelor
councelor
burn councelor e councelor
Carter councelor wrey councelor Caston
councelor epen young councelor
eurn councelor War boys councelor
epon councelor
Eon councelor
field councelor W councelor
flatman councelor Paul epon counc
Fleming councelor eping young councelor
geek councelor War boys councelor gold
coun epong councel Guthrie councelor
eping Yong councelor hadingham councelor
eong councelor Hicks councelor eong
councelor humph councelor e penong
councelor
Mansel uh councelor war booys councelor
maton councelor war boys councelor melon
councelor War boys councelor mayor
councelor epong councel moley councelor
epong councelor Müller councelor epen
young councelor Norris councelor War
boys councelor utton councelor warboys
councelor parore councelor epin young
councelor Phillips councelor war boys
councelor
Pratt councelor War boys councelor
Richardson councel eping counc
councelor War boys councelor Stringer
councelor War boys councelor Turner
councelor War boys councelor War boys uh
myself councelor War boys councelor
wellam councelor War boys councelor
Whitehead councel Paul
[Music]
epinion okay thank you for the voting
that is um 177 chair will you be
exercising your casting vote Yes I will
and uh my vote goes to to councelor eek
penong thank
[Music]
you I hereby declare councelor ekpenyong
duly
elected and Council eong uh well done
and uh I'd like you now to um read and
then sign your Declaration of acceptance
of
office thank you chair I Paul eong
having been elected to the office as
Vice chairman of hereby declare that I
take that office upon myself and will
duly and Faithfully fulfill the duties
of it according to the best of my
judge I undertake to be guided by the
suffk local code of conduct in the
performance of my functions in that
office uh chair I will sign the
Declaration at the mo the the nearest
practical opportunity thank you and I'd
just like to say a few words uh I'm very
pleased to take up this role and would
like to thank fellow counselors for
electing me to an important role within
the council I look forward to assisting
the chairman and the council in this
role with energy and enthusiasm and my
cumulative experience of business and
Council work thank you very
much thank you okay moving on then to uh
item three which is apologies for
absence
please thank you chair I have not
received any apologies for absence and
as we know that everybody is present I
will not be conducting the roll call so
we can move move on to the next item
thank you thank
you and that's item four which is
Declaration of Interest by
counselors are there any Declarations of
Interest i' Che that as
none item five this is MC SL 20/1 to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 23rd July 2020 for accuracy
only are there any issues with the
accuracy please
show excellent could I have a
proposer I'm happy to propose that as
councelor hadingham
Council Hingham thank you and can we
have a second there
I'm happy to to propose as a seconder
rather second Julie flatman councelor
Julie flatman thank you councelor uh
corporate manager governance and Civic
office will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair if councilors can
reply with for against or abstain
councelor Amar
Morrison for councelor
Brewster
sorry four councelor burn four councelor
Carter four councelor Casten four
councelor eurn four counc
epong four councelor field four
councelor flatman four councelor Fleming
four counc geek four councelor gold four
councelor Guthrie four councelor
hadingham four councelor
Hicks four councelor humph four
councelor Mansel four councelor maton
four councelor melon four councelor
mayor four councelor moley four
councelor Müller four councelor Norris
four councelor utton four councelor
parore four councelor Phillip four
councelor Pratt four councelor
Richardson four councelor scarf four
councelor Stringer for councelor Turner
for councelor warboys for councelor
wellam four councelor Whitehead
four chair that is
carried thank you the minutes of the
meeting have been confirmed and be
signed at next practical opportunity
um I'd now like to move to item six
which is the leader's announcements uh
councilor Moy
please thank you very much chair welcome
back to the chamber everyone throughout
the year and especially over the past
six months of covid-19 I would like to
recognize all our staff as the unsung
heroes of local government as has our
prime minister our staff have worked
through have worked through sometimes
difficult personal circumstances always
with the best interests of mids
residents at the Forefront of their
minds we recognize what has been
achieved in managing and helping to
mitigate the spread of covid-19 in
addition to maintaining vital services
to Residents and
communities miduk remains one of the
safest places to live with only two
newly confirmed cases within the last
week this is the lowest number across
the whole of suffk so stick with it
suffk we can do
this I was want to pay tribute to
counselors who have continued to
represent their residents and helped
share important public
messages working together we are
achieving good outcomes for the people
who live and work in mids
suffk some specific specific recent
achievements I want to
highlight padic house Redevelopment
received the go-ahead creating 16
affordable homes for
I we have received £800,000 in
government hunding for electricity
microgeneration and solar storage
carports as part of our climate change
initiatives great progress has been made
on the Regal Theater refurbishment and
extension as part of The Stone Market
visioning
work Gateway 14 consultation is underway
this is an opportunity for the community
to be heard and will help support our
economic
recovery a £200,000
investment in strad strad book sorry
stradbrook pool and fitness center has
now been completed and we've now started
a 2.2 million upgrade and extension to
the mids suffer Leisure Center in Stow
Market which includes a new gym poolside
features and changing
rooms excuse me the Zill Awards which
includes improvements to thirston
railway station new electrical vehicle
vehicle charging points in Stow Market
improvements to the MS Lane children
play area in i a new car park in deham
and conversion of the granery in
Wingfield into a children's nursery each
of these are creating communities with
bright and healthy
Futures working together with babber we
secured 100,000 to provide safe and warm
accommodation for homeless people and
rough sleepers this
winter and our inaugural Innovation
Awards 2020 have been launched this is
recognizing Forward Thinking businesses
large and small the closing date is this
Sunday for nominations so if you have
any of your local businesses in mind uh
please please get your nominations in in
very very quickly the end date for
nominations is 27th of September this
Sunday and it will be held virtually on
the 3rd of
November which brings me on to councelor
hadingham
councelor lvin addingham what can I say
about our outgoing chair Lavinia has
approached the task with energy and
enthusiasm both within the chamber and
also as part of her Civic
functions it is a shame that the last
six months have curtailed some of her
duties out and about in our communities
however her chosen by Charities have
benefited from her Endeavors to the tune
of
1,244
78p Lavinia has been perhaps an
unconventional chair with her some
irreverent style and she's kept us on
our toes throughout I applaud her I'm
determined that Levin's talents will not
go to waste and I would like to take
this opportunity to announce that
Council hadingham will join the cabinet
as the portfolio holder for housing with
immediate effect where her abilities
will be put to good use thank you
Council hadingham thank you
[Music]
chair thank you councelor moley are
there any questions for councelor moley
chair if I may it's um councilor eburn
here councelor eburn yes please um it's
not so much a question I just wanted to
um Echo um councelor moley's um comments
with regards to the co response to covid
and particularly um where you mentioned
the staff as Heroes so I just wanted to
to Echo those and um say you know we
really do appreciate everything that the
staff do and I think the particularly
trying circumstances you can be trying
to speak to a staff member or know that
they're trying to say deal with a
developer or or whatever with a say a
crying toddler in the background and
trying to balance work life balance or
homeschooling or whatever but whatever
um their home challenges have been um in
during this covid period they've still
delivered Beyond and above um you know
the expectations and I think in the
relationships with us as counselors and
how we together try to carry out our
work um we really do appreciate
everything they've done so thank you
chair just for allowing me to to say
that to Echo the leader's comments thank
you it's my pleasure and thank you to
both of you um really well said and uh
really important points thank
you okay moving on then to item seven
which is the designation of committees
and joint committees and we're going to
appoint the following committees and
Joint subcommittees mids overview and
scrutiny committee development control
committee A and B planning referrals
committee mids suffit Licensing and
Regulatory committee joint audit and
standards committee and a joint
appointments
committee could I have a proposer to
appoint all the Committees listed on the
agenda thank you chair I'm happy to to
propose the recommendations thank
you councilor Moy thank you and could I
have a second there uh yes chair I I
would like to second that thank you
councelor pong thank you and the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office will now take a roll vote call
roll call
vote thank you chair if members can
reply with for against or abstain
councelor Amma Morrison uh what are we
voting on the um you're voting on the
actual formulation of the Committees
you're appointing the Committees for
this year so we're constituting the
Committees um so that then we can um the
next paper will then actually populate
those
committees H uh four I guess okay
councelor
Brewster four councelor burn four
Carter four councelor Caston four
councelor
eurn four councelor epong four councelor
field four councelor flatman four
councelor Fleming for councelor Geek for
councelor gold for councelor Guthrie
four councelor Hingham four councelor
[Music]
Hicks four councelor humre four
councelor Manel four councelor maton
four councelor melon four councelor
mayor four councelor moley four
councelor Müller four councelor Norris
for councelor
uton councelor uton sorry for councelor
parore for councelor Phillips for
councelor Pratt four councelor
Richardson four councelor scarf four
councelor Stringer four councelor Turner
four councelor War boys four councelor
wellam four and councelor Whitehead B
chair that is
carried that is carried before we begin
um on the next item councelor Morrison
are you having difficulties with um
connection no councelor Morrison okay
thank
you okay moving on now we're going to uh
agenda or rather item number eight um
I'd like to invite Emily you the mon
sorry Mr chairman I'm sorry to interrupt
could just ask on a point of order
something if I may certainly yes please
um councelor am Morrison has posted a
gif video into the chat box uh which was
posted at the time that you started your
speech as chairman and the monitoring
officer has asked him to remove it and
he hasn't could I just have Clarity from
the monitoring officer about the
appropriateness of posting videos in the
chat room please yeah firstly I'd like
to say councelor Morrison um I did say
I'd be open itd be fair and I'd be I'd
be quite nice but I will be firm um
that's inappropriate and I'll hand you
over to the monitoring officer to uh
decree on
it chair with your Indulgence um I would
prefer not to to comment at this stage
it's not an appropriate point of order
um however councilors will see that I
have asked for it to be removed and I
will deal with it outside of the meeting
thank you okay councelor Morrison I'd
like to remove it now please or give me
a reason as to why
not
councelor Morrison are you still there I
mean it's it's kind of funny right no
it's not funny this is a formal meeting
remove the
post and tell me when you've done
it okay we'll continue while you sort
that out okay so um over to Emily Yu the
monitoring officer to introduce the
paper MC stroke2 str2 Emily
thank you chair I would like to present
the report uh in recommendation 2.1 the
council is asked to agree the political
balance and allocation of seats as
detailed in appendix a this Remains the
Same as the balance that was agreed by
the council at its July meeting in
recommendation 2.2 the council is asked
to agree the appointment of committee
members as per appendix B which is
included in the tabled papers pack chair
I'm happy to answer any questions on
this paper and would seek a proposer and
seconder for the recommendations thank
you thank you uh do we have a
proposer thank you chair it's councelor
moley I would be happy to propose thank
you and a second please and chair it's
councelor Eber and I'll be happy to
second that thank you councelor re bur
thank you very much uh are there any
questions on
this councilor Hicks I believe your
hands
up I can't see it it shouldn't be up Mr
from before my apologies yeah no problem
thank you okay in that case if there are
no questions and the corporate manager
governance and Civic office will now
take a roll call
vote thank you chair if members can
reply with for against or abstain
councelor Amma
Rosen
councelor are you
there okay I'll carry on and come back
to you councelor Brewster four councelor
burn four councelor
Carter four councelor Casten four
councelor eburn four councelor epin
young four councelor
field councelor field
okay I'll come back to councel sorry
it's four okay couldn't get my mouse
back onto the okay this screen thank you
councelor flatman four councelor Fleming
four councelor geek four councelor gold
four councelor goth four councelor
hadingham
four councelor Hicks four councelor
Humphries four councelor Manel four
councelor maton four councelor melon
four sorry councelor was that four four
councelor mayor four councelor moley
four councelor Müller four councelor
Norris four councelor utton four
councelor parore four councelor Phillips
for councelor Pratt four councelor
Richardson four councelor scarf four
councelor Stringer four councelor Turner
four councelor War boys for councelor
wellam for councelor Whitehead for thank
you chair as that was an overwhelming
vote for um we won't um re re back to
councelor Morrison yeah thank you agreed
um there that is
carried now going to move on to the
election of chairs and vice chairs of
committees and um to elect a chair and
vice chair for the following committees
and joint committees mids overview
scrutiny committee development uh
control committee A and B mids Licensing
and Regulatory committee joint audit and
standards committee and a joint
appointments committee may have
nominations for the chair of overview
and scrutiny
committee could I have a proposer um
chair could I propose um Keith wellam
for chair and Keith scarf for vice chair
thank you chair chair can I second
that thank you councilors uh noted are
there any further
nominations
sorry I had problems with my my mouse
then it put me on to mute um the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair as um we have both
nominations um for vice chair and chair
of scrutiny and no other nominations we
going to be taking those together so if
you can just say for against or
abstain thank you councelor
Rosen for councelor Brewster for
councelor
[Music]
burn councelor
burn four four counc
Carter four councelor
Casten four councelor eburn four
councelor eping Yong four councelor
field four councelor flatman four
councelor Fleming four councelor geek
four councelor gold four councelor
Guthry four councelor hadingham four
councelor Hicks for councelor Humphries
for councelor Manel four councelor
Matson four councelor melon four
councelor mayor four councelor moley
four councelor Müller four councelor
Norris
four councelor uton four councelor
parore four councelor Phillips four
councelor Pratt four councelor
Richardson four councelor scarf four
councelor Stringer four councelor turnup
four councelor War boys four councelor
wellam four councelor Whit head four
thank
you
okay um in that case councelor wellam is
duly appointed chair of overviewing
scrutiny committee well done and uh for
the vice chair we are looking at
councelor scarf well
done we now move on to committee uh
planning committee a uh can have a
proposer yes chair could I could I
nominate councelor Hicks please for the
chair thank you
hi chair I'd like to second that
nomination councelor
mayor chair I'd like to propose Sarah
Manel please it's uh Wendy councelor
Wendy
Turner I do we have a second for Council
ATT Turner please sorry for Council
Manel councelor Mike Norris
I'm happy to Second The Proposal thank
you uh corporate manager governance
Civic office will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair again if members
can reply with the councilor's name that
you are voting for thank
you councelor Emma
[Music]
Rosen Mansel councelor
Brewster councelor Hicks councelor burn
councelor Hicks councelor
Carter councelor Manel councelor Caston
councelor Hicks councelor eburn
councelor Manel councel
epong councelor Hicks councelor field
councelor Mansel councelor flatman
councelor Hicks councelor Fleming
councelor Hicks councelor
geek councelor Manel councelor gold
councelor Hicks councelor goth
councelor Hicks councelor Hingham
councelor Hicks councelor Hicks myself
councelor Hicks councelor humph
councelor Hicks councelor Manel
councelor Manel councelor
[Music]
Matson councelor Manel councelor
melon councelor Manel councelor mayor
councelor Hicks councelor moley
councelor Hicks councelor Müller
councelor Hicks councelor Norris
councelor Manel councelor utton
councelor Manel councelor parore
councelor Hicks councelor Phillips
councelor Manel councelor Pratt
councelor Manel councelor Richardson
councelor Hicks councelor scarf
councelor Manel councelor Stringer
councelor Manel councelor Turner
councelor Manel councelor War boys
councilor Manel councelor wellam
councelor Manel Mr Whitehead councelor
Hicks chair that is a tie will you be
exercising your casting
vote Yes I will councelor
Hicks thank
you therefore councelor Hicks is duly
appointed chair of development control
committee a um we'll now move on to the
vice chair of development control
committee a do we have a
proposer yes chair I'd like to propose
Dave Müller for the deputy chair of
development control
a and I Council HS I'd like to Second
councelor
Müller and chair as councilor eburn here
as Sarah Manel was not successful as
chair of planning a I would like to
sorry development control committee a
I'd like to propose her as Vice chair
thank
you uh councilor Mike Norris I'm Al so
happy to second that
proposal thank you councilors that's
councelor Miller and councelor Mansel
the corporate manager governance and
Civic office will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair again if councilors
can reply with the name of the counselor
you are voting for thank you councelor
Emma
Rosen are we going to do this every time
should we just skip to the end
Asberry okay everyone um we're going to
stop the vote at that point we're going
to close the meeting for about 5 minutes
and uh we'll come back to
you
mute
oh counselors and um and the general
public welcome back I'm sorry about the
small interlude um councelor Morrison um
this is fair warning uh you've been
you've asked several times uh whilst
voting what we're voting for which shows
to me a lack of
Interest you've used inappropriate use
of chat even though given clear
directions on how to use that chat in a
formal meeting and I believe that your
last comment was unprofessional and
becoming the counselor this is fair
warning that if you persist I will move
to the vote to have you removed from the
meeting is that
clear
yeah yes chair thank
you I say uh just to assume where we
were we're now taking a vote for the um
Vice chair of the planning committee
a and I'll hand you over to the uh
corporate uh manager governance and
Civic officer who will now take that
roll call vote thank you chair so just
to remind councelors we're voting for
councelor Müller or councelor Manel so
if you can reply with the counselor's
name you are voting for thank you
councelor Amma
Rosen for what it's worth Manel
councelor
Brewster uh councelor Müller councelor
burn councelor Müller oh yes councel
Muller sorry councelor
Carter councelor Mansel councelor Casten
councelor Miller councel
eburn councel Manel councel
[Music]
epong councelor Müller councelor
field councelor Mansel councelor flatman
councelor Müller councelor
Fleming councelor Müller councelor
geek councelor mancil councelor G
councelor Müller councelor Guthrie
councelor Müller councelor hadingham
councelor Müller councelor Hicks
councelor Müller councelor Humphries
councelor Miller councelor
Manel councel Manel councelor maton
councelor Manel councelor melon
councelor Manel councelor mayor
councelor Müller councelor moley
councelor Müller councelor councelor
Müller councel Muller councelor Norris
councelor Mansel councelor utton
councelor Manel councelor parore
councelor Muller councelor Phillips
councelor Manel councelor
Pratt councelor Mansel councelor
Richardson councelor Muller councelor
scarf
councelor Manel councelor Stringer
councelor Manel councelor turnup
councelor Manel councelor War
[Music]
boys councelor War
boys my apologies I was muted uh
councelor Manel councelor wellam
councelor Manel councelor Whitehead
councel
Muller chair that's a draw again are you
going to exercise your C vote yes I am
and it's councelor
Miller therefore councelor Miller is
appoint is duly appointed Vice uh chair
of development control committee a may I
have nominations for the chair of De
development control committee B
please yes um thank you chair councelor
burn here and I would like to propose
counselor Kathy
Guthrie
thank you can we have a second please
yes councelor gold here I'd like to
Second the uh nomination of councelor
gri thank you councilors uh are there
any further nominations councelor War
boys yes I raised my hands chair um uh
I'd like to propose councelor Andrew
Stringer for
chair and chair I'd like it's councelor
wellam I'd like to Second councelor
Andrew Stringer for
chair thank you counselor so we have two
nominees councelor Guthrie and councelor
Stringer uh the corporate manager
governance and Civic office will now
take a roll call
vote thank you chair again if you can
reply with the councilor's name you're
voting for thank you councelor Amma
Rosen string
G
sorry
stren gar okay thank you councel
Brewster councel Guth councelor
[Music]
burn Council Guthrie Council
Carter Council
Stringer councelor Casten councelor
Guthrie councelor eburn councelor
Stringer councelor epong councelor
Guthrie councelor field councelor
Stringer councelor flatman
councelor Guthrie councelor Fleming
councelor Guthrie councelor geek
councelor Stringer councelor gold
councelor Guthrie councelor Guthrie
councelor Guthrie councelor hadingham
councelor Guthrie councelor Hicks
councelor Guthrie councelor
Humphries councelor G gurie councelor
Manel councelor Stringer councilor
Matson councelor Stringer councilor
melon councelor Stringer councelor mayor
councel Guthrie councelor moley
councelor Guthrie councelor Müller
councelor Guthrie councelor Norris
councelor Stringer councelor utton
councelor Stringer councelor parore
councel Guthrie councelor Phillips
councelor Stringer councelor Pratt
councelor Stringer councelor Richardson
councelor Guthrie councelor scoff
councelor Stringer councelor Stringer
councelor Stringer councelor Turner
councelor Stringer councelor War boys
councelor Stringer councelor wellam
councelor Stringer councelor Whitehead
councelor
guffies thank you that again is 177 so
chair will you be using your casting
vote Yes I will and um councelor Guthrie
uh therefore councelor Guthrie is duly
appointed chair of development control
committee B may have the nominations for
the vice chair of development control
committee B yes chair um I would like to
nominate yourself councelor Humphries as
Vice chair of development control
B mistake here hello Mr chair second
please James Caston here I'd like to um
nominate yourself councelor Humphrey as
Vice chair
please thank you uh Council War boys I
guess this is further nominations yes I
would like to count in in interest is
sort of uh spreading the load a little
bit I'd like to nominate Council
Stringer for vice
chair thank you do we have a second
there yes chair councilor wellam I'd
like to Second councelor Stringer for
vice chair Council wellam thank you uh
the corporate manager governance and
Civic office will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair if members can
reply with the name of the councelor you
are voting for thank you councelor Emma
Rosen
Stringer councelor Brewster councelor
Humphries councelor
burn councelor humph councelor
Carter councelor Stringer councelor
Caston councelor Humphries councel
eurn councelor Stringer councel
epong councelor humph councelor field
councelor Stringer councelor flatman
councelor Humphries councelor Fleming
councelor humph councelor
geek councelor Stringer councelor gold
Guthrie councelor Humphries councel
hadingham councel humph councelor Hicks
councelor humph councelor
Humphries Council humph councelor Manel
councel Stringer councelor maton councel
Stringer councelor melon councelor
Stringer mayor councelor mayor councel
humph councelor moley councelor humph
councelor Müller councelor humph
councelor Norris councel Stringer
councelor utton councelor Stringer
councelor parore councelor humph
councelor Phillips councelor Stringer
councelor
Pratt councelor Stringer councelor
Richardson councel humph councelor scar
councel Stringer councelor Stringer
councelor Stringer councelor Turner
councelor Stringer councelor War boys
councelor Stringer councelor wellam
councelor Stringer councelor Whitehead
councelor
humph okay chair again that's a draw
will you be exercising your casting vote
Yes I will I vote for councelor
hph therefore councelor hre's duly
appointed Vice chair of development
control uh committee B may have
nominations for the chair of Licensing
and Regulatory committee please thank
you chair I'd like to nominate Council G
thank
you thank you chair I'd like to nominate
councelor string Dan Pratt councelor Dan
Pratt I'd like to Second councelor
Pratt um actually council is that not
second in for Council Stringer can you
just go for that proposal second
proposal again
please may miss sorry I I would I would
like to nominate councelor Dan Pratt for
the chair of Licensing thank you and I
and I second that thank you I crossed on
the comms there thank you I do have a
seconder please um um um yes yes chair
councelor flatman I'm seconding um Kathy
Guthrie thank you so we have two
nominees which councelor Guthrie and
councelor Pratt
um corporate manager governance and
Civic office will now take a roll call
vote thank you counselors um if you can
reply with the name of the counselor
you're voting for thank you councelor
Emma
Rosen Pratt councelor
[Music]
Brewster Council Guthrie councelor burn
Council Guth councelor
[Music]
Carter sorry councelor Pratt
sorry councelor Casten councel Guffy
councel
eurn councel Pratt councelor
[Music]
epong councelor Guffy councelor field
councelor Pratt councelor flatman
councelor Guthrie councelor Fleming
councelor Guthrie councelor
geek councelor Pratt councelor gold
councelor gri councelor gri
councelor Guthrie councel Hingham
councel Guthrie councelor Hicks
councelor Guthrie councel humph councel
Guri councelor Manel councelor Pratt
councelor maton councelor Dan Pratt
councel melon councelor Dan Pratt
councelor mayor councel Guthrie
councelor moley councel Guthrie
councelor Müller councel Guthrie
councelor Norris councelor PR counc
councelor Pratt councelor parore councel
gri councelor Phillips councelor Dan
Pratt councelor
Pratt myself councelor Dan Pratt
councelor Richardson councelor Guthrie
councelor
scoff councelor Pratt councelor Stringer
councelor Pratt councelor turnup
councelor Dan Pratt councelor W boys
councelor Dan Pratt councel wellam
councelor Dan Pratt counc Whitehead
councelor
GIS chair that again that is a a draw so
um will you be exercising your casting
vote uh yes I will councelor Guthrie
therefore councelor Guthrie is appointed
chair of Licensing and Regulatory
committee I may I have nominations to
the vice chair of the Licensing and
Regulatory committee please I'm sorry
chair could somebody please mute me I've
locked in spasm and I'm vocalizing do
apologize yeah no problem councilor car
fully understood and see to that now
thank you yes chair I'd like to nominate
councelor Daniel Pratt for the position
thank you uh chairman I'd like to second
that nomination of councelor Pratt um I
would like oh sorry um I would like to
nominate councelor Dave
Müller chair um I would like to second
that this is
councel councilors thank you there are
two nominees then councelor pratz and
councelor Miller
the corporate manager governance and
Civic office will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair if members can
reply with which councelor you are
voting for thank you councelor Amar
Rosen right councelor Brewster councelor
Muller councelor burn councelor Müller
councelor
[Music]
Carter can can't yeah you'll need to
unmute him yeah that's fine oh
you can't
oh unfortunately we can't unmute
counselor Carter but if you would like
to put on the chat whether you're voting
for or against we would take that if
you're able
[Music]
to sorry um can't chat at M your fers
don't work for typing man unmute uh okay
councelor C please ow sorry sorry
councelor Pratt thank you councelor
Caston councelor Miller councelor eburn
councelor Pratt councelor
epong councelor Müller councelor field
councelor Pratt councelor flatman
councelor Müller councelor Fleming
councelor Müller councelor
geek councelor Pratt councelor gold
Guthrie councelor Muller councel
hadingham counc Müller councel Hicks
councelor Müller councel
humph councelor Müller councelor Manel
councelor Pratt councelor maton
councelor Dan Pratt councelor melon
councelor PR councelor mayor councelor
Müller councelor moley councelor Müller
councelor Müller councel mullet
councelor Norris councelor Pratt
councelor uton councelor Pratt councelor
parore councelor Müller councelor
Phillips councelor Dan Pratt councelor
Pratt myself councelor Dan Pratt
councelor Richardson councelor Muller
councelor scarf councelor Pratt
councelor Stringer councelor Dan Pratt
councelor Turner councelor Dan Pratt
councelor War boys councelor Dan Pratt
councelor wellam councelor Dan Pratt
councelor Whitehead councelor Müller
okay chair that again is a draw would
you like to exercise your um casting
boat yes I would um councelor Müller
therefore councelor Müller is duly
appointed the vice chair of Licensing
and Regulatory committee um I'm aware
we've been sat for some time now and uh
Council car it's not fair on you so I
suggest we now take a short break of 10
minutes if we can convene back here at
1850 we'll see you then thank
you
good evening everybody welcome back I
can see uh from the chat room that
everybody is still present so we'll
continue with the meeting but before I
do um it saddens me actually councelor
Morrison that even though I gave you
fair warning to desist from using the
chat room inappropriately that's has
been done yet again at the beginning of
this meeting I laid out the protocol
quite clearly and it included etiquette
and it's clearly evident from your
posting in the chat room it's been
broken not just once but twice
please
desist because of that and I'm a fair
man and I did give you fair warning I
now need to escalate that warning and
therefore under Council procedure rule
20.1 uh. 3 I'm moving that councelor
Morrison not be heard further um for an
explanation of what that actually means
I'll defer to Emily mule for a further
description Emily thank
you thank you chair uh yes Council
procedure all 20 t.3 requires that the
counselor be be no further heard uh that
means that councelor Morrison will not
be permitted to debate any of the
remaining items on the agenda however he
will still be able to vote chair I just
also like to point out that if this
motion that you have proposed is
seconded it will move straight to a vote
without discussion thank you
chair thank you uh that's abundantly
clear um I'm seeking a second it to that
proposal I'm happy to second that
coun councelor Miller thank you
therefore um corporate manager
governance and Civic office will now
take a roll call
vote thank you chair please can you
reply with for against or abstain cancor
a Morrison against councelor Brewster
for councelor burn for counc
Carter counc Carter
okay I come back to councelor Carter
councelor Caston for councelor eburn
against councelor epong for councelor
Fields against councelor flatman for
councelor Fleming for councelor Geek
against councelor gold four councelor
gri four councelor hadingham
four councelor
Hicks C
Hicks okay I'll come back to councelor
sorry okay councelor
Humphries four councelor Manel against
against councelor Matson against
councelor melon abstain councelor
mayor for councelor moley for councelor
Müller for councelor Norris against
councelor utton against councelor parore
for councelor
Phillips against councelor
Pratt against councelor Richardson for
councelor scarf against councelor
Stringer uh against but could I have a
point of order are we not allowed to
debate
this counc Stringer
no councelor
Turner against councelor War boys
against councelor wellam against
councelor
Whitehead
for councelor
Carter yes sorry about that I'm against
okay thank you you for
that with one extension here if you'd
like to announce
that so I believe the vote was 16 for uh
wrong 17 for 16 against we've one AB
ition therefore it's carried and
councelor Morrison would be not heard
further chairman I just say as the group
leader I have asked councelor Morrison
to um remove his comments and to act in
a courteous way thank you chair Council
Le bur as always I'm I'm gracious for
your intervention and um yeah and like
me you believe in eut and doing the
right thing so thank you for that
support and councelor Morrison uh be
well well advised to Listen to Your
Leader thank
you
okay uh moving on then with the uh with
the bulk of the business um we're now
looking for nominations for the co-chair
of the joint audit and standards
committee could I have a proposal please
thank you chair is councelor moley here
I would like to propose councelor
Müller do we have a second there and
chair councilor flatman here I'm happy
to Second are there any further
nominations uh yes it's councilor Manel
I did did raise my hand um I'd like to
propose Mike councelor Mike
Norris uh councelor Wendy Turner I'd
like to second that please thank you so
that's two nominees um councelor Müller
and councelor Norris the corporate
manager governance and Civic office will
now take a roll call
[Music]
vote thank you chair um members if you
can reply with the counselor's name who
you are voting for thank you councelor
Amar Morrison
Norris councelor
Brewster uh councelor Müller councelor
burn councelor Muller councelor
Carter councelor Norris councelor Caston
councelor Müller councel eburn councel
Norris councel epon
councel Muller councelor field councelor
Norris councelor flatman councelor
Müller councelor Fleming councelor
councelor geek councelor Norris
councelor gold councelor Miller
councelor gothy councelor Muller
councelor hadingham councelor Müller
councelor Hicks councelor Müller
councelor humph councelor Muller
councelor Manel councelor Norris
councelor Matson councelor Norris
councelor melan councelor Norris
councelor mayor councilor Muller
councelor moley councelor Müller
councelor Müller councelor Müller
councelor Norris councelor Norris
councel utton councelor Norris councelor
parore councelor Müller councelor
Phillips councelor Norris councelor
Pratt councelor Norris councelor
Richardson councelor Muller councelor
scarf councelor Norris councelor
Stringer councelor Norris councelor
Turner councelor Norris councelor W boys
councelor Norris councelor wellam
councelor Norris councelor Whitehead
councelor
Müller chair that that is a draw again
will you be exercising your casting vote
Yes I will councilor Miller therefore
councelor Miller is duly appointed
co-chair of joint audit and standards
committee may have nominations for the
co-chair of joint appointments committee
please hi it's um councelor hadingham
here I'd like to um propose um councelor
Susie
moley thank you can we have a second it
please yes chair and I'm happy to I'm
happy to second that thank you
councilors are there any further
nominations corporate uh manager
governance and Civic office will now
take a roll call vote okay counselor so
if you can reply with for against or
abstain councelor
Morrison
uh abstain councelor Brewster four
councelor
burn councelor
Carter cancer
Carter I will come back to you sorry
sorry about that I'm get get me stuff
worked up so sorry about this computer
doesn't like me um that's
fine ah fudy did I
sorry four sorry thank you councelor
Casten four councelor eurn four
councelor epong four councelor field
four coun
flatman
four councelor Fleming for councelor
Geek abstain councelor gold for
councelor gothy four councelor hadingham
four councelor Hicks four councelor
humph four councelor Manel abstain
councelor maton against councelor
melon for councelor mayor four councelor
moley four councelor Müller four
councelor Norris
four councelor utton abstain councelor
parore four councelor Phillips abstain
councelor
Pratt abstain councelor Richardson four
councelor scarf abstain councelor
Stringer abstain councelor Turner
abstain councelor War
boys councelor War boys
my apologies I thought I abstain thank
you councelor wellam abstain councelor
Whitehead
for carried and therefore councelor
moley is duly appointed co-chair of
joint appointments committee we're now
moving on to item 10 of the agenda genda
and uh this is the
mc23 which the appointments to the
outside bodies for 2020 to 2021 uh refer
to appendix a in the table papers and
I'd like to invite the leader to produce
or introduce paper
mc23 and move the recommendation in the
report thank you I'm really sorry
nothing quit as he come through the
votes thank you chair I'm I'm pleased to
introduce the appointments of
Representatives on the outside bodies
and Partnerships for
2020/2021 this is paper MC
20202 sorry
sl3 um and I would like to ask for a
second thank
[Music]
you do yes please could I second the um
recommendations thank you thank you so
we do have a proposer we do have a
seconder and a corporate manager
governance and Civic officer will now
take a roll call
vote uh sorry Council Le I didn't see
hand please please carry on um thank you
chair it was just that there are two um
tbc's um on the report um and one is for
the suffk flood risk management scrutiny
and um could we put Keith wellam in as
as that substitute and on the suffk
health scrutiny committee where it says
subt BC could we put councilor s Sarah
Manel in on that thank you chair and I
appreciate pu to go back to your
proposal a second us again yeah thank
you Council Eber apologies for not
seeing your hand councelor
Moy um I'm happy with the councilor
wellam as a sub for the flood
risk um committee could you just say
again what the second one was Rachel
sorry counc Ean it was for um I think
it's the suffk health scrutiny committee
said to two down from that yes Sarah
Manel yes I'm I'm happy with that thank
you thank you councilor moley thank you
chair second are also happy thank you uh
yes chair also happy thank you fantastic
okay the corporate manager governance
and Civic office will now take a rooll a
roll call
vote thank you chair if members can
reply with four against or abstain counc
Morrison abstain councelor Brewster four
councelor burn for councelor
four four councelor Casten four
councelor eburn four counc epong four
councelor field four councelor flatman
four councelor Fleming four councelor
geek four councelor gold four councelor
Guffy four councelor hadingham four
councelor Hicks four councelor humph
for councelor Mansel for councelor maton
against councelor melon for councelor
mayor four councelor moley four
councelor Müller four councelor Norris
four councelor utton four councelor
parore four councelor Phillips four
councelor Pratt abstain councelor
Richardson four councelor scarf four
Stringer for councelor Turner for
councelor war boys for councelor wellam
for councelor Whitehead
for on my calculation that is carried um
item 11 the appointment of councilors to
the shared revenues partnership joint
committee uh the nominations have been
tabled and can have a proposal please
yes I'm happy to propose
chair um yes chair
councelor flatman I'm happy to Second
thank you we have a um proposer and a
seconder therefore the corporate manager
governance and Civic office will now
take a roll call
vote sorry I'm point of order chairman
may we have the names
please um yes it's councelor Susie moley
and councelor John Whitehead yeah and
they have their nominations have been
tabled that's why they're not read
out yes it's just for benefit of anyone
who's
listening thank
you thank you chair if members can reply
with for against or abstain chair could
I just have clarification please oh no I
yeah um on the shared revenue and
benefits
partnership it says the representatives
have to be on the cabinet is that
correct I believe it is actually
counselor but I'll just defer and uh get
that um absolutely agreed with the
offices bear with
me chair if I can provide some clarity
on on that uh question the shared
revenues partnership committee is an
executive committee it discharges
executive functions and therefore the
membership from our Council must be from
the cabinet thank
you C hopefully that answers your
question
um well it does but I just feel that
that's such an important position at the
moment particularly with the number of
people that are having to claim benefit
and I just wonder whether there is any
opportunity for another member from the
opposition group to at least be involved
in
that um Council I do I do understand
exactly what you're saying and the
reasons for it but I'm afraid that's not
possible you thank you
therefore we do have a proposer and a
second
and corporate manager governance and
Civic office will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair if members can
reply with four against or abstain
councelor Morrison abstain councelor
Brewster four councelor burn four
councelor
Carter abstain councelor Caston for
councelor eurn against councelor epong
four councelor Field obain councelor
flatman Four councelor Fleming for
councelor
Geek against councelor gold for
councelor Guthrie four councelor
hadingham
four councelor Hicks four councelor
Humphries four councelor Manel against
councelor maton against councelor melon
abstain councelor
mayor B councelor moley for councelor
Müller for councelor Norris against
councelor utton against councelor parore
for councelor Phillips against councelor
Pratt against councelor Richardson for
councelor scarf against councelor
Stringer against councelor Turner
against councelor War boys against
councelor wellam against councelor
Whitehead
for my my calculations with the
abstentions that is carried bear with
me
okay we're now moving on to item 13
appointments to Joint Gypsy and traveler
Steering group um council is asked to
appoint four counselors to the
Joint my
apologies my apologies um I'm on item 12
I skipped ahead of myself their
appointments to the suffer joint
Standards Board um the nominations have
been tabled and could I have a proposal
Please Mr chairman I'm very happy to jro
Brewster I'm very happy to propose these
nominations as shown on the schedule
here do we have and do we have a
seconder please yes I'm happy to second
that sorry it's councelor hadingham
thank you uh therefore the corporate
manager governance and Civic office will
now take a roll call vote
I'm sorry just I'm sorry councelor H but
just for the benefit of those that
haven't got the papers who might be
watching online I think could we just
always read the names out thank you yes
exactly please yep good point and uh my
remiss I'll just do that now bear with
me so the names of the counselors will
be councelor EP eek penong mat and
Norris and to the vote
please thank you chair members if you
can reply with for against or abstain
thank you counc Morrison stain councelor
Brewster four councelor burn four
councelor
Carter for councelor Casten for
councelor eurn four counc epong four
councelor field four councelor flatman
four councelor Fleming four councelor
geek four councelor gold four councelor
Guthrie four councel Hingham four
councelor Hicks four councelor humph
four councelor Manel four councelor
Matson four councelor melon four counc
mayor four councelor moley four
councelor Müller four councelor Norris
four councelor uton four councelor
parore four councelor Phillips four
counc
Pratt four counc Richardson four counc
scarf four counc Stringer for councelor
Turner for councelor war boys po
councelor wellam for councelor Whitehead
for chair that is
carried thank you that is carried uh
moving on now to item 13 again so the
appointments to Joint Gypsy and traveler
Steering group The councelor is asked to
appoint four counselors to the Joint
Gypsy and traveling Steering group
nominations have been tabled and those
names are councelor flatman councelor
hading councelor Stringer and councelor
field could I have a proposer please
um I'm happy to propose chairman
councelor Fleming thank you councelor
Fleming and a second
please I'm happy to Second councelor
melan thank you councelor melan um
corporate manager governance and Civic
office will now take a roll call vote
thank you councelors if you can respond
with for against or abstain councelor
Morrison stain councelor Brewster four
councelor burn for councelor Carter
four councelor Casten four councelor
eurn four councelor epong four councelor
Fields four councelor flatman four
councelor Fleming four councelor geek
four councelor gold four councelor
Guthrie four councelor Hingham four
councelor Hicks four councelor
humph four councelor Manel four
councelor Matson four councelor melon
four councelor mayor four councelor
moley four councelor Müller four
councelor Norris four councelor utton
four councelor parore four councelor
Phillips four councelor
Pratt four counc Richardson four
councelor scarf four
councelor Stringer for councelor Turner
for councelor war boys for councelor
wellam for councelor Whitehead
for chair that is
carried that is carried uh we're now
moving on to item 14 appointments to
council working groups a councilor has
asked to appoint counselors to the
following working groups as tabled and
I'll call out the names after each these
groups Community governance review
working group which will be councelor
moley Whitehead Mansel and utton the
Constitution working group which will be
counselor Hicks Manel and scarf the
member Learning and Development working
group which will be counselor moley eurn
and Phillips and a local plan working
group councelor burn Guthrie field and
Stringer could I have a proposal
please thank you chair I'm happy to
propose Council moley thank you and a
seconder please I'm happy to second that
thank you it's councelor hadingham thank
you before we go to the vote I see
councelor eburn you have your hand
up thank you very much chair I just
wondered if we could ask the um monitor
of sorry monitoring officer um when the
community governance working group is is
likely to meet um because I understand
there are some um issues that need
resolving so I just wonder when that was
going to start working thank you chair
no problem do we have an answer please
thank you chair um unfortunately I'm not
able to give a exact date uh this
evening but um councilors I'm sure will
be aware that we've recently received
the draft recommendations for the review
of County Council electoral divisions
which in some areas does have a KnockOn
effect with our Parish Wards and
therefore we're currently working
through what that means and whether we
would need to convene a meeting of the
working group to consider those issues
thank you chair thank you and moving to
the vote then the corporate manager
governance and Civic office will now
take a roll call
vote thank you chair members if you can
reply with for against or abstain
councelor Morrison stain councelor
Brewster four councelor burn four
councelor
Carter four councelor Caston four
councelor eurn four councelor epong four
councelor field
four councelor flatman four councelor
Fleming four councelor geek four
councelor gold four councelor Guthrie
four councelor hadingham
four councelor Hicks four councelor
humph four councelor Mansel four
councelor Matson four councelor melon
four councelor
mayor
sorry four councelor moley four
councelor Müller four councelor Norris
four counc uton four councelor parore
four councelor Phillips four councelor
Pratt four counc Richardson four counc
scarf four councelor Stringer four
councelor Turner four councelor War boys
four councelor wellam four
councelor whiteheads
for and that is carried we're now moving
to item 15
mc24 extension to the appointment of the
independent persons for code of conduct
complaints I'd like to invite Emily Yu
and the monitoring officer to introduce
the paper
mc24
Emily thank you chair I would like to
present report mc24 which seeks the
council's approval to extend the
appointment of the independent persons
for a further two years the independent
persons were jointly recruited by Baba
and mids District councils ipswitch
burough Council and suffk County Council
in 2018 for a 2-year term with the
option to extend for a further two years
the other partners have already agreed
the extension of the appointments and we
have all been very impressed with the
high quality of advice received from the
Independent persons please could I ask
for a proposer and seconder for the
recommendations and again chair very
happy to answer any questions on the
paper thank you thank you um therefore
do we have a
proposer uh yes chair Kathy Guthrie
Council Guthrie I'm happy to propose
thank you councelor and a seconder
please uh yes chair it's councelor
Richardson I'm happy to Second the
recommendations in the report thank you
thank you we have a proposal in a second
we're now going to move to questions and
debate but counselors may ask as many
question questions as you like however
they need to be relevant so please stay
on track think about your question
before you pose it and um it must be
about the subject that's under
discussion when you're raising that
question uh when we get to the debate
element uh councilors only be allowed to
speak once and for three minutes and I
need to inform you that that will be
timed so therefore let's start the
questioning are there any
questions please just raise your hand
and we'll come to you in
turn
give it another 30 seconds no questions
uh let's move to debate would anybody
like to start the
debate excellent in that case the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair again if councilors
can um reply with four against or
abstain councelor
Morrison abstain councelor Brewster four
councelor burn four councelor
Carter four councelor Casten four
councelor eurn four councelor epong four
councelor field four councelor flatman
four councelor Fleming four councelor
geek four councelor gold four councelor
Guthrie four councelor Hingham four
councelor Hicks four councelor
humph four councelor Mansel four
councelor maton four councelor melon
four councelor mayor four councelor
moley four councelor Müller four
councelor Norris four councelor utton
four councelor
parore sorry four councelor Phillips
four councelor Pratt
four councel Richardson four councel
scarf four councelor Stringer four
councelor Turner four councelor War boys
four councelor wellam four councelor
Whitehead
four
carried that is carried moving on now to
item 16 recommendations from committees
16a is J St 19 St 24 the annual treasury
management report for 2019 to 2020 I'd
like to invite councelor Miller to move
the recommendations on the agenda
councelor Miller thank you very much
chair yes um I would like to move the
recommendations as stated on the agenda
and if I may chair just give a brief
summary of the actual
report um the report explains in more
detail the factors affecting the
strategy and activities including the
regulatory framework economic conditions
interest rate and liquidity risk towards
the end of the year the spread of the
Cor Corona virus began to change Life As
We Knew It covid-19 which had first
appeared in China in December 2019
started spreading across the globe
causing plummeting sentiment and force
in financial markets not seen since the
global financial crisis interest rates
which had remained steady during the
year at
0.75% were reduced by the bank of
England to 0.25% in March and then
swiftly reduced again to a record low of
0.1% at that time the UK government
introduced a number of measures to help
businesses and households impacted by a
series of ever tightening social
restrictions culminating in pretty much
the entire lockdown of the UK now more
specifically for mids suffk uh one
regarding banking activities the council
exceeded the daily bank account limit on
one occasion by
129,000 this was as a result of a high
value payment being received too late in
the day to be able to invest it two the
council has increased ined its
short-term debt by 6.4 million this was
to take advantage of lower interest
rates following the increase in the
public works loan board rates the
council lent a further 4.1 million to
cifco limited and a further 4.7 million
to Gateway 14 limited all investment
activities undertaken were in accordance
with the approved counterparty list the
council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
at appendix C of the report the Council
made another investment of 2 million in
higher yielding strategic pulled fund
investtech Diversified income fund
investment in funding Circle has reduced
as unallocated funds have been reclaimed
and existing loans repaid this was
208,000 of the 423,000 previously
invested leaving the balance as at 31st
of March 2020 at
215,000 the council is compliant with
the upper limits for interest rate
exposure and the investment activity
undertaken for the year was done so in
priority order of security and liquidity
over yield as prescribed in the treasury
management strategy the audit and
standards committee discussed this
report on the 11th of August and it was
UN unanimously supported um could I have
a seconder
please chair I'm happy to Second it
councilor Whitehead thank you very much
thank you if there are any questions um
I'm sure the um the assistant director
for finance will be able to answer those
questions for you thank you thank you
chair thank you uh councelor Miller and
uh thank you for your report and as you
said I believe uh Katherine steel is
here from the assistant director
corporate resources and you also have uh
Melissa Evans which is the corporate
manager finance and commissioning
procurement if you need their help um so
we'll now move on to questions and
debate as I said before you may ask as
many questions as you like however they
must be relevant to the subject under
discussion and must be a question so
please think about it and if the
questions be asked before there's no
need to ask it again um when we get to
the debate element counselors will only
be allowed to speak for three minutes
and only once and it will be timed thank
you so therefore um let's go in order uh
counselor eburn question
please um thank you very much chair um I
have three questions if I may um and if
if I I'll run through them all they're
not they're not lengthy on appendix B
page 5 1.1 it refers to the increase in
Public Works loone board interest rates
um I just wanted a confirmation of
whether how that will affect us using
the Public Works loan board and then on
appendix C on page 60 um at
2.8 um we ref refer to um the amount of
e Equity that we have in CCO and is that
paragraph effective saying that the
equity we have as a council in cifco is
used um for the buying costs of the
Acquisitions and then the last one is on
2.9 of the same appendix um could you
just confirm whether the investment
income mentioned in that paragraph is
net thank you very much
chair great questions councilor Miller
um thank you very much chair um could I
ask either the assistant director for
finance or the corporate manager for
finance to answer counc reburn questions
please thank you
chair thank you chair I'll I'll start
and I may need assistance with with one
of
those um the pwl increase um that was
asked about that only affects us when we
actually want to take borrowing from
them so any borrowing that we have
already taken out from the pwl is at a
fixed rate um the rates do vary uh twice
a day I believe the rates are published
so they are constantly changing and say
it will only impact us when we actually
want to take further borrowing from the
pwl um I think um Melissa rans was going
to pick up the CCO question can I just
double check uh counselor Ean on your
last question I know you were asking if
it was net um return on appendix C page
60 paragraph 2.9 it refers to investment
income in general I just wonder if
that's
net um and could I just come back on
your first your answer to the pwb point
um it's whether we've got any plans to
um borrow at the moment um so therefore
is an increase affecting any plans we've
got thank
you uh answer to your second part again
first the pwb no we don't have any
current plans because the shortterm
rates are so low at the moment so we're
we're keeping borrowing at the
shortterm level um I might have to ask
Melissa if she can answer the the 2.9
question as well if I ask Melissa just
to come in and answer the cfco one and
then see if she could also answer the
that 2.9 as well if not I'll have a look
at it in
between yeah thank you chair thank you
councelor reburn for your questions um I
think can probably help on the uh the
2.9 one as well um in terms of the
equity in cifco every time we make a
purchase 10% of that is attributable to
uh Equity so you're correct that is the
the buying costs of each asset so 10% of
each of the cost of that asset is then
attributable to equity um in terms of
your question at
2.9 um that is gross that income so
we've obviously got the borrowing costs
uh as well so the 3 Mill is the 3
million you're referring yes yeah yeah
that's the gross gross income thanks for
those thank you happy C
Ruben fantastic okay uh councilor Austin
please uh thank you um in the main
report it says that mids exceeded his
bank account with Lloyds by
129k um could I have an explanation of
that and did that incur any um penalties
I can try and answer that one um I
believe it might have been a payment we
had come in as a seal payment it came in
too late in the day for us to be able to
lend it out because there's a c off
point in the day as to when we can
actually do uh Bank transfers so it it
came in too late to do that um and no
there are no penalties associated with
exceeding that limit it just means we
had a little bit more cash sitting in
there that day and it would have been
corrected the next day when we did the
cash flow projections for the the
following day thank
you Council Ron happy uh moving on then
to counselor phield
please thank you uh I'm sure in these
documents it says that we uh obtain
£200,000 worth of interest for an
investment of5 m million in
ccla to confess I can't find the line
with that on it at the moment um looking
at the table uh in appendix C above
three above par 33 we seem to receive
73,000 of interest from CCO I just
wondered uh what investment we have to
how that
compares the uh CCO investment is the
the loans that the council lends to
cifco so the interest is the payment on
those
loans and how much are those
loans I think for mids it currently
stands at about 30
[Music]
million thank
you
sorry hit the wrong button so there are
no more hands up for questions um so
therefore let's move on to debate who'd
like to
start councelor maton
please thank you chair yes I just wanted
to explain why I won't be able to um
vote to support this um paper or or to
note this paper because um two two
reasons the main thrust of what um we've
been um doing over over that year has
has been satisfactory and I I'm on the
committee um however we are exposing
the public and the council to
considerable risk through our
investments in CCO and I I think that is
a risk we cannot um
justify and
secondly we are not um we're not moving
fast enough to
uh to
disinvest the from the various funds
that we have money in at the moment in
support of our climate emergency em
policy um which really requires us to to
remove our money from supporting fossil
fuels entirely so for those reasons I
will not be able to vote to knowe
this thank you uh that's understood and
uh councelor Ean
please thank you very much chair um I
just wanted to um make some comments um
with regards to particularly the the
wording in appendix C I feel that we
should be um show a lot more clarity um
in that area um particularly with how
we're reporting on cifco so for example
my question that I just asked um you
know and I asked whether the investment
income was was net or not because it
wasn't clear yet for example our
reporting on ccla is extremely clear to
the public and we can very very clearly
see how long we've had the um ccla loans
for what the whether Investments net or
gross and so on but it's just not clear
with cifco there isn't a date saying
when CCO started um and there isn't
um you know there there isn't the kind
of clear points about um net or gross
income in the um commentary and I feel
we need to just be much more open and
maybe have um I'm surprised that that
there isn't more in the um report about
our investments in CCO and how exactly
how much we've um got invested there so
I I really think um we should have much
more clarity on that that point thank
you very much
chair no that's it's a very good point
actually and um I'll just ask the
assistant director of corporate
resources she wants to come back with
any uh any comment for that Katherine
please thank you chair yes of course
we'll uh look at those comments from
councelor eurn um when we prepare the
the next reports on Treasury management
thank
you thank you for
that thank you uh councelor
Richardson uh thank you very much chair
I just wanted to add a brief comment to
that um that I completely understand um
everything that Council ebans just said
but I do think that actually what we've
been presented with is a very
comprehensive report so as always I'd
like to thank um the assistant director
for corporate of corporate resources and
the finance team um for helping put this
together and also councelor uh Müller
for his very comprehensive introduction
um so thank you to all those involved um
it's a really useful and interesting
report so I will definitely be voting uh
to to note his content thank you
chair thank you councelor anybody else
like to say anything
just give you a couple of
seconds no I'd like to Echo the points
that councel richson made actually
there's a lot of work gone in there and
uh it's not one person it's a group of
people so well done to you all it's not
easy uh trying to get it right but
hopefully with those comments from
counselor eburn it may be more inclusive
in the future who knows um therefore
councelor Miller do you have anything
further to add uh no thank you chair and
I would also like to reiterate um my
great thanks to um Katherine and her
team thank you
that's noted the corporate manager
governance and Civic office will now
take a roll call vote and we're looking
uh particularly at recommendation 3.1
and
3.3 thank you chair if if members can
reply with four against or abstain
councelor
Morrison abstain councelor Brewster four
burn Council
Carter
for councelor Casten for councelor E
against councel epong for councelor
field against councelor flatman for
councelor Fleming for councelor Geek
against councelor gold for councelor
Guthrie for councelor hadingham
four councelor Hicks four councelor
Humphries four councelor Mansel against
councelor Matson against councelor melon
against councelor mayor for councelor
moley for councelor Müller for councelor
Norris against councelor utton against
councelor parore for councelor Phillips
against councelor
Pratt against councelor Richardson for
councelor scarf against councelor
Stringer against councelor Turner
against councelor War boys against
councelor wellam against and councelor
Whitehead
four um councelor Carter I think you
want to um just vote again I I think um
you You' made a mistake so would you
like to vote again and we'll note
that yes please I do apologize but
managed to get my hands to the right
place of my
actually so excited I said the wrong
thing
um I wanted to vote against okay thank
you very much we will change that vote
thank
you okay so that's 17 for 16 against one
abstention
carried item 17 overviewing scrutiny
committee work plan 2020 to 2021 I'd
like to invite Council wellam to
introduce his report which is for noting
councelor wellam thank you chair at the
last council meeting the annual report
on the overview and scrutiny work in
2019 2020 was received the annual report
included a draft work plan for 2020
2021 this draft has been further
developed and can be found on pages 83
and 84 of the agenda
papers our next topic for review is the
is Council representation on outside
bodies to assist in this review members
who represent the Council on outside
bodies will be asked about the
effectiveness of mids suffer Council
representation on that body an email
request for information will be sent out
shortly in February we will be reviewing
the effectiveness of management of Open
Spaces on housing developments we need
examples of good and not so good
practice in respect to maintenance of
Open Spaces play equipment and so on
provided by in developers so I would
like to propose that the work plan be
noted and I look for this proposal to be
seconded Council well um there's no need
for that actually this is just for
noting anyway but um I do get I do get
your sentiment in your gist thank you
anyway um are there any questions for
councel Willam uh councelor utton
please uh yes um as you probably realize
I do have concerns about the number of
people that having to apply for
Universal Credit um and I believe I
mentioned it it's in the minutes of the
last meeting so I'd like to ask the
chair and the vice chair of scrutiny
committee either mids or the joint
scrutiny to um consider putting that on
their work
plan if I may chair um yes we will be
requesting ing an information bulletin
in respect of the effect on Council rent
collections due to uh covid restrictions
the Furlow scheme and an increase in the
number of Universal Credit claimants
timing will be discussed with the
officer with the corporate manager Lee
Crowell we need to be sure that scrutiny
can add value by reviewing the topic
chairs and vice chairs would expect to
discuss this topic informally with
offices in November December with a view
to receiving an information B bulletin
or report in
February that's really good to hear
thank you very much chairman thank you
yeah very good point councilor as well
well raised um we now have councelor
Whitehead thank you chair could I just
ask in terms of the planning enforcement
review will you be intending to get any
feedback from Parish
councils um I'm not exactly sure um I
would I would guess that there would be
some uh requesting feedback from from
Members um but I would I will take that
up with uh with the officer thank
you thank you excellent are there any
further questions I'll give you a couple
of seconds just to
think no good councelor Willam you have
anything else to add no thank you very
much chair thank you and thank you for a
comprehensive report again and and for
the work you're doing is uh is
appreciated um and that report was for
noting Only We Now move on to uh item 18
mc206 mids District Council sheltered
Housing Services charges for 2020 2021
and I'd like to invite councelor flatman
to introduce their paper
mc206 and to move the recommendation in
that report Council flatman thank you
chair the report relates to the
sheltered housing service charges for
mids suffk for The Current financial
year and seeks the agreement of council
that they are not increased from the
2019 and 2020 levels members will recall
that this matter was brought before
Council on the 27th of February
2020 and at that meeting council did
resolve that the service charges should
increase by2 a week and utility charges
increased by 5% members will also recall
that there was a procedural error made
at that meeting which is explained in
more detail in the report the nature of
the error was such that an external
legal advice was sought to the clar to
clarify the council's position that
legal opinion concluded that the
recommendations should stand and the
service charges should increase however
the housing team are required to work
strict deadlines when inform forming
tenants of rent and service Char charart
changes and the legal opinion could not
be obtained before that deadline for
that reason the annual rent increased
letters sent to midu suffk sheltered
tenants made no mention of service
charge increases for 2020
2021 it would have been possible to
write a second letter of course based on
the legal advice which included the
increase in charges but by this stage we
were in
lockdown this necess necessitated a
change in the way that the sh sheltered
housing service was provided with fer
home visits and a reduced staff presence
on site although the sheltered housing
team continued to work very hard to
support the our older tenants it did not
feel reasonable to increase service
charges at that very point when the
delivery of the service was having to
change for that reason we are
recommending that the sheltered housing
service charges for 2020 2021 do not
increase as originally planned I'd like
to re re I'd like to recommend the
report at 3.1 and 3.2 and I would ask
for a
seconder thank you thank you thank you
councelor platman um can I have a second
please hi it's um it's councelor hading
here I'm happy to second that thank you
very much um we'll now move to questions
and debate and as before um you can ask
as many questions you like um however
Keep On Track keep it relevant to the
actual point we're talking around and
then we move to debate you can speak
once and it be for three minutes and
that will be timed um I can already see
councelor eburn
please thank you very much chair um and
thank you for that report councilor
fetman um one of when this was
originally voted on um back in February
when um we had a um pretty much a tied
vote um as to half the council voting
for it and half against um it was put
into the budget for
20221 um so will it be bought in the
budget this February um as a proposed
increase again despite it not being
increased for this Current financial
year
and secondly if it is going to be
brought forward again is that going to
be a lump sum um or is it going to be
staggered over several years thank you
very
much thank you for your question
counselor eburn um I honestly don't know
as yet what we're going to do um I'll
ask if the assistant director is in the
room and he can answer that
[Music]
question um hello it's it's um Lee
Rodell tenant services corporate manager
I'm afraid um Gavin fist the assistant
director is not available this evening
um but but I'm here so let me just
adjust my camera um I think with with
the um budget setting for next year
we're still uh working through process
uh and we will be bringing um papers to
council to have those approved at a
later stage I
believe thank you for
that thank you are there any further
questions no okay we'll move into debate
who' like to start the debate
please okay uh councelor Manel first
please thank you councelor Manel are you
there yeah I've I've just managed to
turn my camera and my mic on I think um
yeah thank you I I would just like to
say that I will be voting in support of
this recommendation uh I felt it was the
wrong decision to make back in February
uh and I and I think that in a way it
was a shame that there was the
procedural error and and basically it
just didn't really work out particularly
well uh but I think the council is now
about to make the right decision uh I
didn't feel back in February that we
should be in in in increasing service
charges by such a large amount um so I
would just like to to say yeah this is
the right decision to make at this time
um and any future decision about Rising
um service charges in the future uh will
be taken in due course I'm sure that
will you know we will be debating it
again uh and let's hope we don't have
any more procedural errors uh but I I am
in support of this I think it's the
right decision we should not be
increasing service charges at this
time thank you councelor Manel thank you
thank you uh let's move on to councelor
Richardson please thank you very much
chair um I would just like to start by
saying that I completely agree I think
this is absolutely the right decision I
think it's reasonable proportionate I
think it it at the end of it it
understands exactly um the situations
that some of our residents are facing
and so it's absolutely right that we
should be not increasing service charges
um given what's going on at the minute
um but also I'd just like to take this
opportunity to very briefly place on
record my thanks to the sheltered
housing team for all of the work that
they've done over the last few months
this has obviously been an
extraordinarily difficult um period and
they've had to respond very quickly to
some very challenging situations and I
think they've done a fantastic job and
so I think we as councilors should
should recognize that given that this is
our annual council meeting um but also
on a personal note I would like to thank
councel flatman as well um for her role
as the cabinet member for housing I
imagine it's been um incredibly
difficult juggling both the communities
portfolio and the housing portfolio in
the midst of a global pandemic whilst
also working as a as a teacher which I'm
sure will have kept her busy outside of
outside of council work so I'd just like
to place on record my thanks um to
council flatman as well for all of her
leadership um in taking on the housing
portfolio and to say to also councelor
hadingham um the best of luck um for the
future um in your new role as the
cabinet member for housing so we look
forward to welcoming you as part of the
team thank you very much
chair thank thank you councelor
Richardson and I'd just like to thank
while I've got a chance the whole team
over Co they've done a fantastic job
with housing people and looking after
our sheltered housing um residents and
all the other me um all the other
officers and workers across the council
that have actually helped out with this
situation when they've been asked to do
other jobs that as you know it's not
their remit but they have all really
done a fantastic job
thank you councilors and um I would like
to formally ask that to be minuted those
thanks to the um the shelard housing
team and the whole team that were
involved and uh thank you for your
service it is appreciated councelor
field
please thank you chair yes I just wish
to point out I think has been said
before we thought this was the wrong
decision back in the decision in
February was
incorrect um
increasing cost to the vulnerable
portions of our population one of the
most vulnerable portions never seems uh
a good thing to be doing and certainly
in that time it was my perception the
cost of um certain utilities was
reducing so it did seem to be a wrong
thing to do so obviously one supports
the uh the uh new decision now not not
to increase charges um I was just going
to comment I I do try and keep in touch
with our local sheltered housing we we
we we used to run a a club there uh
believe it or not that's been not been
operating for a few months but
nevertheless one keeps in touch with
some of the residents um as far as
possible um they are receiving good
support I was particularly pleased to
see that some of the carers have managed
to uh as far as I see self reorganize
themselves so that they not moving from
from location to location in a way that
would transmit virus so that
demonstrates that not only is the
management team trying pretty hard um
indeed uh various of the staff are using
their own initiative in a way that's to
be applauded to my mind so I will sure
be supporting this um believe we got the
decision right and hope that we will
think of that next
year thank you councelor field well said
and uh councelor Phillips
please yes um I'm I'm really fully in
support of our sheltered housing teams
but I'm a little bit dismayed at the
fact that it's been reported to me on
several times that um single parents
have being housed within the sheltered
housing schemes as emergency housing um
with the Advent of this pandemic I do
believe that young children and people
that are visiting them isn't a very good
atmosphere for the people that work in
that and and the elderly people are very
concerned about this is there an answer
from the team that this will continue or
or are we going to stop this in the
future I was told that this was a a
oneoff but I'm not sure whether that's
going to
continue thank you CA thank you
councelor Phillips um I'll answer what I
can and then Lee can come in the fact of
the matter Council flatman I I'll jump
in actually and I think we should be
taken outside the meeting with the right
people and right questions asked at time
so we can get the full depth of that
answer okay because it is deserve it and
I think it deserves that time not here
is everybody happy with that thank you
councelor pH you happy with that no not
really because uh I have asked the
question outside the meeting and it has
been pushed to one side I do believe it
should be made public as people are
watching
this okay I do get your point um so ly
councel flatman and then I want you
promised to me that you will take
outside the meeting with councelor
Phillips and address this properly yes
certainly certainly thank you councelor
Phillips um the fact of the matter is we
have a lot of sheltered housing um that
is not taken up and with the pandemic as
it was we had a lot of um families and a
lot of single people that needed housing
and to have those houses sitting empty
was a was an absolute crime so we did
what we could do for the people who
needed the most so if Lee you want to
come in and add to
that um yeah thank you councilor flatman
I think I just add that that um we have
had some sheltered accommodation being
used as temporary accommodation in
recent times but in pretty much every
case um they had been people who would
have qualified for sheltered housing
they were of the right age they were
just using uh some of the guest room
accommodation for short periods um and
there's one scheme where which is
predominately Bungalows but there's a a
building nearby where some of the flats
use as temporary accommodation um but at
the moment now our homes's provision is
expanding um uh and uh my understanding
is that all of the the temporary
accommodation is now um specific and
designated as
such thank you um let's take a yeah
councelor eburn
please
thank you very much chair um firstly can
I just um make a request that whenever a
councelor asks a question and it's not
addressed fully in the meeting that that
the response to that goes to all
counselors and not just the counselor
that raised it thanks but just on on
this particular paper I think um you
know I'd Echo um councilor Fatman's
comments as well with regards to the
work that the housing team overall have
done and I but I do think we need to be
really cognizant of the most vulnerable
residents in our society and
particularly all of their needs and this
this is particularly related to the
their finances you know and the stress
and worry that an increase such as this
can can cause some of our most
vulnerable um and elderly residents so I
I will be voting for this and I'm
pleased as others have said that we're
now making the right decision and I'd
urge um that everyone to really consider
um very deeply what is um done at budget
time in this regard thank you very much
chair thank you C thank you councelor
reburn thank you counselor and uh
councelor flatman would you like to sum
up um well I just um you know very glad
to bring this report forward and I think
that's the right thing to do at this
given time thank you chair thank you uh
corporate manager manager governance and
Civic officer will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair if council could
reply with four against or abstain
councelor
Morrison for councelor Brewster four
burn four councelor
Carter four counc Caston four councelor
eurn four counc epong four councelor
field four councelor flatman four
councelor Fleming four councelor geek
for councelor gold for councelor Guthrie
for councelor hadingham
four councelor Hicks four counc humph
four councelor
Mansel Council
menel four councelor Matson four
councelor melon four councelor mayor
four counc moley four councelor Müller
four councelor Norris four councelor
utton four councelor parore four
councelor Phillips four councelor Pratt
four counc Richardson four councelor
scarf four councelor Stringer four
councelor Turner four councelor War boys
four councelor wellam for councelor
Whitehead for chair that is
unanimous so glad we're so aligned on
that really important issue so that is
carried um and as a reward we'll take a
slight intermission um conscious we've
been going for well over an hour now
without a break so therefore if
everybody could be back in at quarter
past the hour
please
welcome back
everybody still getting used to the
headset um welcome back everybody and uh
moving into the final fies really we're
looking at item 19 now which is changes
to the current planning system
consultation and I'd like to invite
councelor burn to introduce paper
mc207 and to moove the recommendation in
the
report
uh sorry counc Council Burns sorry I
almost forgot we're getting towards the
guillotin now aren't we so um so the
Gilling rule comes into effect at 2030
and therefore it is appropriate to ask
Council to extend the meeting therefore
can I have a proposer
please I'm happy to propose or second
depending on who got in
first you're in first counselor thank
you and a second please I'm happy to
Second it's counc re fantastic in that
case uh let's go to the vote
please thank you chair so we're voting
in favor to extend the meeting um if
councilors could reply with for against
or abstain councelor
Morrison against councelor Brewster for
councelor burn for councelor
Carter four councelor Casten four
councelor eurn four counc
epong four councelor Fields
four councelor flatman four councelor
Fleming four councelor geek four
councelor gold four councelor Guthrie
four councelor hadingham four councelor
Hicks four councelor humph four
councelor Manel abstain councelor maton
for councelor melon for coun mayor four
councelor
moley four councelor Müller four
councelor Norris four councelor uton
four councelor
[Music]
parore it looks like councelor parmor
has left the meeting we'll carry on at
the moment councelor
Phillips four councelor
Pratt four councelor Richardson four
councelor scarf four councelor Stringer
four councelor Turner four councelor War
boys four councelor wellam four
councelor Whitehead four chair as that
is carried anyway we won't um try to get
councelor parore back into the meeting
at this point Thank you understood and
uh thank you councilor is carried um
councilor Burns sorry to steal your
thunder I know you're poised um now is
your turn to um introduce your paper
please uh thank you chairman
um yes uh I'm I'm aware that it's
getting late but thank you for the
extension because these are two two uh
the last two items are fairly well are
very important items and um I'm glad
we've got the opportunity to discuss
them this evening
um even so I'll try and keep my my in
introductions as as short as possible um
on the 6th of August at the same time as
its better known white paper planning
for the future which I'll come on to uh
in the next item the government
published a consultation on changes to P
planning policy and
regulations entitled changes to the
current planning system um and there was
an 8-week consultation for this and it
closes on the 1st of
October um you will have seen in in your
uh agenda pack paper MC 20 uh 7 and
noted the four main CH changes proposed
in the consultation at paragraph
1.3 these are explained in paragraphs
4.2 to
4.22 and our draft responses to the
consultation questions are attached as
an appendix to the to to the
paper
um the draft
responses followed a cross Council
cross-party discussion that we held on
the 10th of
September and those responses that I'm
recommending to you this evening Express
concerns regarding the four main
proposals I'll just very quickly for the
benefit of those people who are
listening uh
that haven't got access at the moment to
to those the four changes are changes to
the St standard method for assessing
local housing need the second one is the
securing of first homes that's capital F
Capital H because that's the scheme sold
at a discount to market price for
firsttime buyers and uh third one is
temporarily lifting the small sit
threshold below which developers do not
need to contribute to affordable housing
um up to 40 or 50 units uh at the moment
it's uh it's up to 10 or it's it's sorry
it's uh above 10 10 or above um uh when
sill becomes affordable they're now
talking about it only becoming
affordable um
when only requiring a Sil contribu ution
when it's over 40 or 50
units um and uh the fourth one is
extending the current permission in
principle to major development instead
of smaller developments as it is in at
the
moment
uh our draft responses
um Express concerns about all those
proposals but we particularly have
serious concerns regarding the proposed
changes to the standard method for
assessing housing need which if
implemented could see midsi's uh housing
need numbers rise from its present 535
dwellings per year across the plan
period to just over
750 dwellings per year now I'm sure I
don't need to explain to you the
implications for our local plan our
communities and our rural landscape if
that came into being but I feel I should
also highlight the potential impact on
our housing land Supply
position um may I say that the assistant
director for sustainable communities Tom
Barker helped draw together the views
that expressed that were expressed by
our cross par party um round table on
the subject and so if there are any any
questions uh of detail I will refer them
to him if I may so I'm proposing the
recommendations in your papers at
paragraphs 3.1 and
3.2 and I would ask for a
second thank you councelor burn do we
have a second to
please I'm happy to I'm happy to Second
Mr chairman thank you Council
Breer okay we'll now move into the
questions and debate and as before uh
please keep your questions uh as you can
ask as many as you like but keep it to
the points uh make it relevant and one
that will get an answer and when we move
on to debate again staying on track
please you have a three minute period
and three minute only so moving into
questions first on the list councelor
eburn um thank you chair but I would
like to actually propose um an amendment
to the recommendation if I may um the
recommendation is at 3.2 and I'd like to
propose an amendment that after the
words Cabinet member singular it will be
for mids suffk for planning um they
include the word and this OPP opposition
spokesperson for planning councilor
Andrew Stringer thank you
chair Council burn
thoughts um my thoughts on that are that
uh um sorry could I just ask for my
seconder first please
chair I'm not if that's the correct
process I'm not quite
sure yes it is yes if we do go can we
have a second please I'm happy to second
that chairman thank
you councelor burn uh yes well Council
Stringer was a member of the of the
Roundtable discussion that um uh fed
into these these responses and
I uh I can't see any reason I would be
happy for for councelor Stringer to to
join me and councelor Guthrie sorry not
councelor Guthrie
councelor uh arthy because it is plural
uh the assistant director for
sustainable
communities will be in collaboration
with the two because it's a it it the
two councils because um it is a it is a
joint response so uh it'll be myself
councelor arthy and um if you wish I
can't see any reason why councelor
Stringer shouldn't be a part of that uh
that collaboration thank you very much
for that councelor burn thank you okay
we'll come back to that later as
substantive motion so um continue with
the questions I can see that councelor
geek
please thank you chair um I would uh
just like to ask one thing about the
answer to question three um and the
question asks essentially if the
standard method is best adjusted by
using the house pric to earnings ratio
now um we have said that we like the
standard method as an effective way of
setting housing need and the response
reflects this the response of yes but we
don't like as we said its adjustment we
don't like the so-called affordability
ratio for three very good reasons that
are all cited in the answer so as the
question is about the adjustment of the
standard method not the standard method
itself why is the response
yes Council burn would you like me to
ask um Tom Barker who is the assistant
director of sustainable communities if
you can assist on
that um yes please by mean I'm just
please feel fre to my notes but uh but
yes might be a slight delay because
Tom's had a few um technical issues
tonight so just bear with
us evening Tom over to
you
evening we're still having those
technical issues I'm afraid you're
coming through as a very weak dalc if
that
helps um does this help sector perfect
thank you okay sorry for that so I think
the question was
um um around there being concern with um
the uh the affordability ratio
essentially um and how that impacts on
the um how that impacts on housing need
um so what we're answering here is that
the workplace based median house price
to median earnings ratio from the most
recent year which provides us with the
standard method at the moment is
perceived to be unacceptable and that's
not really part of the
consultation the standard method is what
the standard method is um and so I think
the yes is kind of accepting that I
would be happy to remove the yes from
that and just simply move straight into
the narrative um which suggests
supporting the the the ratio from the
most recent year um because I'm not sure
that the yes is necessary in this in
this instance
could I come back on that chair
certainly thank you um thank you very
much um it's just that when you
summarized what we were answering you
left out the word adjust and the
question's got the word adjust in it
it's not really a question about
calculating the standard methods
Baseline it's a question about of
adjusting the standard methods Baseline
and that is to do with the affordability
ratio as I understand it so it be great
if you could take out the
yes um yes I don't think that would
change the uh the agreed nature of the
response so working that through with
the with the cabinet members I think
entirely acceptable great thank you very
[Music]
much thank you Council G um so let's go
for councelor Manel please your question
or questions uh thank thank you um I
hope I'm I'm working this time um now uh
whilst I completely appreciate that this
is a a big piece of work uh and quite a
short timeline um I personally found it
quite difficult to juggle the document
itself with the questions and then
trying to find the answers uh and I
would have I would have really
appreciated a cut and paace job with a
question before the answers uh but
that's just me and maybe I'm I'm a bit
dense um but I can see lots of answers
um lots of responses relating to first
home and and the fact that they are
going to form part of the um affordable
mix in any development but is there any
scope for commenting on whether we
actually support the whole concept of
first homes per say uh whether or not
they count as part of the affordable
allocation or not um I I understand the
responses but I just wondered if there
if there if that is a in the questions
and B whether we have any any any
opinion about supporting or not or
otherwise of the whole concept of first
homes um I'll I'll refer that one if I
may to to uh Tom Barker because that's a
a technical detail that I'm not as
familiar with as I should be to answer
that particular
question I don't know whether you are
Tom are
you the
um apologies yes the um the consultation
the um the principle of first homes um
was a consultation that was earlier in
the year um and I don't believe this
Council provided a response to that
consultation um and that was largely
about how deliverable they will be so
the the questions as part of this
consultation are framed in a very
specific way and there isn't one that
that um
provides a a ready means to address the
principle itself so the questions relate
to the the answers relate to the
questions that have been asked rather
than addressing the principle of first
hes um um could I could I come back on
that um I wasn't I I know I may not I'm
not on top of things but I wasn't aware
that there was a consultation about
first homes um a and was there a
specific reason why this Council didn't
respond to it um or make councilors
aware that there was a consultation
about such
things Tom that's you again I'm afraid
yes sorry I'm I'm just juggling various
things on the screen excuse me um
councilor Manel I have to come back to
you outside the meeting on that point
okay thank
you
um I I would like to ask you Tom even
though the specific question that um
councilor menel was referring to isn't
asked within the uh the consultation
document could we not give an an opinion
along those lines are we not I'm just
looking at the question itself which
is um yeah very specific and very
technical but uh C can we not can we not
give a view on on whether we we feel
that the first home idea is is a good
one um we can of course add anything
that we wish into the consultation
respon responses councilor burn um so
there would be an opportunity to amend
the response on that basis um subject to
agreement amongst um
counselors as to the
principle could we discuss that perhaps
with Council Manel out of the meeting as
to what the precise wording uh needs to
be and if we've got Council Stringer
eventually um if that's approved if
we've got Council Stringer
um discussing it with us for for the the
final submission um would that would
that meet with your
approval um uh yes
counselor good okay well we'll do that
then is there anybody else
yes there is so moving on so uh we'll
now go for councelor bom field
please okay my question really is about
the maturity if you like to call it that
of this document its stability it's
labeled a
draft uh we've seen sort of two two
earlier versions one very very
uh doubtful if you like and one that was
looked at by the the working group on
the local
plan uh where we expressed a whole range
of issues this document to my mind seems
to be uh considerably enhanced from that
it still doesn't seem
terribly clear on these points like
should there be do we be agree with
there being an accelerating Factor at
all in the standard method based on uh
affordability ratios
and particularly their latest
modification to that
acceleration which to my mind is highly
volatile in that it takes uh two numbers
10 years apart and makes a calculation
based on the difference of those numbers
clearly both numbers can vary R
radically year to year so that generates
High volatility in the estimates and I'm
not convinced that we've got a a refined
answer to that if that's less more
polite than other words I could use uh
there are other areas too in the areas
of first homes and the concern about the
impact of those upon the um a
availability of affable houses of
various tenures and and uh shared
ownership for
instance and I would be personally far
from convinced that that our
interpretation of those things is
necessarily correct um you know does sh
does first homes uh subtract
substantially from shared
ownership um and on what basis because
we seem to be concerned about the uh
numbers proposed and yet the number of
First homes is not radically different
from the number of shared ownership
building so my question and there is a
question buried in there is is that um
you know just what level of revision are
we going to make to a document or need
we make to make it something which will
impress um a set of uh civil servants
what level of revision are we going to
make to a document we're potentially
agreeing
tonight um again Tom uh I need your help
with that
one um
thank you counselor um councelor field
in respect of your first point around um
the accelerating Factor the final
paragraph of answer
four um addresses issues of
volatility and um we certainly sought to
capture the the essence of um what you
what was discussed within the um Round
Table discussion um within that that
final paragraph of answer for um and uh
I think the answer to the point around
first homes and shared ownership is that
yes first homes does subtract from
shared ownership ultimately um first
homes usurps shared ownership if they're
in
Conflict um so for example um 30% of the
affordable mix is shared ownership um
that would if if this came into being
that would become 25% first homes and 5%
shared
ownership does that does that final
paragraph of um answer four I think it
it gets substantially there but it was
just concerning that that we we make no
proposal of any sort of how we could
really improve that it does say appropr
guys just going to interrupt we're
moving into debate here question is
short succinct that deserves an answer
um so we can continue this into debate
which is fine but um I think you you
asked the question and and you did get
an answer so if you're happy I'd like to
move on because there is a whole host of
people Wai to ask
questions a an answer thank you uh
councelor Carter
please uh yes sorry regards first homes
I wanted to know what the definition of
a first home was what the makeup was it
is this a standard building of a
two-bedroom to up or are we including
here adaptive properties uh that may
actually be for um that Cas for disabled
um people to move in uh for wet rooms or
something like this cuz are we by first
time buyers are are we talking that with
so standard standard able-bodied bu
buyers and
uh how do we how's that being defined
and nor say are these first homes means
tested by any point
um it's all very well with definition of
of a first time buyer
but it's human nature if you even if you
are a firsttime buyer but you got money
to afford another one you're going to
want to go for a cheaper property which
may not
be which could otherwise be used by
somebody who hasn't got the same amount
of
assets who may also require to so what
is a what protect what level of
protection ah
sorry ah
um yeah I
think somewhere along those lines
there's a question just without
the sorry well can can can I attempt an
an answer to that Council Carter
uh the the actual um proposal as set out
in the document is not specific to that
extent it's simply said saying that um a
minimum of
25% of all affordable housing units
secured through developer contributions
should be first homes uh and they're
defined at at um homes that that can be
bought at a discount price
of 30% off market market rate
um if if we have any
uh specific policy regarding affordable
homes that that that meet your
requirements or or meet the requirements
you were just talking about I presume
that they would also be applied to the
25% first homes but uh again Tom can you
can you assist with that
one
um yes you're correct on that councelor
burn I mean there there are um specific
specific technical definitions they're
not provided within the document but
they were provided um in other
Associated documents I don't think here
is necessarily the place to go into
those um specific definitions but I'm
happy to pick that up with councilor
Carter outside the meeting at a broad
level um it is as councilor burn
described
um uh very simply put um new homes for
firsttime buyers at a third 30 or more
per discount um there is nothing there
around number of bedrooms or any of
those kind of things it could just as
equally be a one-bedroom flat as a as a
five-bedroom house um both of those
things could potentially be considered
as first homes um and equally it could
be um an adapted dwelling or a a uh
dwelling specific for those with um
particular additional
needs thank you um hopefully it answers
your question councilor Carter and I
think that uh after work uh post this
meeting might be quite useful for
you okay councelor scarf
please thank you chair um my question
would be uh do you think our response uh
to the document is actually worded
strongly enough um to cite an example um
the number of houses increasing from 10
on smaller sites to 40 to 50 is
something clearly that we object to uh
as both authorities and and the
explanation for that I think is well
documented there but we start off with
um we do not agree that this is an
appropriate approach for Rural districts
such as ours I wonder whether we should
say we strongly disagree this is not an
appropriate approach for Rural districts
such as ours because I feel it has more
of an expression of the sentiment
of what we want to say so I'm basically
asking would that be something that we
could toughen up a bit thank you C
BN
um yeah again I'm I'm I'm looking at the
question
um first part of which is do you agree
with the proposed approach to raise the
small sites threshold for a Tim limited
period um and they don't specify what
that Tim limited period is likely to be
um they're then talking about what is
the appropriate thresh the level of
small size threshold and uh that their
suggestions are 40 to 50 or other please
specify um
so I think I think it would be damaging
to um to our district if it were
increased to any level uh approaching
those that they're suggesting um so
perhaps if the if the general feeling is
yes uh we should increase the strength
of our response there perhaps that might
come out a bit in in in debate rather
than a straight uh question because um I
I can't answer it directly without
reference back to uh the assistant
director um and the rest of the team so
but yes I'm I'm I'm not averse to it if
that if that comes out in debate by all
means let's talk about
it I'm just going to bring in um Emily
Yu just to make a
comment thank you chair I thought it
might just assist uh councilors just to
remind you of the uh recommendations so
recommendation 3.1 is to agree to
actually to respond to the consultation
and 3.2 is to give a delegation to the
assistant director in consultation with
the cabinet member for planning and in
consultation with the green and liberal
Democrat group spokes person for
planning to then take on board all of
the comments that have been made tonight
and in and integrate them into that
response as they F see fit so you don't
actually need to debate the merits of
any comments or or additional points
that you're putting forward this evening
um they just need to be made and then
Tom and the relevant counselors will
take those on board and and add them if
they uh if they fit into the response
thank you chair Emily thank you it's
really useful um yeah it keeps back on
track doesn't it to what the actual
recommendation is because we could go
down rabbit holes on this and speak all
night on this because it's a really
important subject and why wouldn't we
but we can't we haven't got the time
really have we that's why we've got the
working group that's why we've got the
assistant director to actually take
those comments away for us so let's
concentrate on the recommendations uh
and move this along so with that in mind
Council of War boys
please Council War boys you
there we can see you yes I am your
question please yes it's a question um
it it's really about the first uh part
of the uh consultation and it's to do
with the standard method and this
proposed adjustment
Factor um and I uh officer
OBS did calculate for us the effect of
the
um using this proposed adjustment
Factor uh for msuk um the Baseline at
the moment is
456.04 households applying the proposed
adjustment Factor results in
754 homes and that is a dramatic
increase in the
Baseline
um I think the using the standard method
for calculating housing needs is is
really only a starting point that it has
to be informed Council War boys that
that is broaching into debate so
sorry yes the question is why why aren't
we using other information to um
criticize
this
uh using this adjustment Factor
information from um healthy suffer for
instance which uses oness data
to look at demographic changes over the
next 10
years the information is there the
moment our proposed Baseline
fits
the the demographic changes the new
proposal will be way out it would
be twice what is needed okay so let's
try and answer the question then so if I
should I just repeat it no Tom if you
got that if you can answer the question
please I think I um I think I understand
the question which is around um whether
the adjustment factor is the appropriate
mechanism to come up with uh a housing
Target ultimately um and we the the
question is around the algorithm and the
standard method that currently exists
that sets our housing numbers sets mids
suffix at
535 um so there's there's a general
acceptance that um household projections
which would give give you a baseline of
456 are then adjusted in the current
system um to give you a housing Target
of 535 per year and that is what the
local plan is heading for this still
uses the household projections as the
Baseline um it then moves into using
affordability um to impact on the
adjustment and that's where the answers
to
questions uh let me just double check
myself um oh sorry my modern. go has
just stopped um so that's where the
answers to questions 1 to 7 um uh pick
up whether affordability is uh an
appropriate way of um adjusting things
and that's that's what the answers have
provided that that reference the Le rim
review and various other things that say
that actually affordability isn't a
useful um
addition um and it produces a number
which is
undeliverable um so we can look at other
things and certainly um the information
on healthy suffk is is very useful
looking at the suff plus 20 information
is very useful it paints a picture of an
aging population and a range of other
things like that as the all member
briefing um last week will have um shown
those counselors that were able to
attend
um but the the housing targets are set
by government so there isn't a mechanism
for us to add local data
into um that assessment in the current
system nor would there be in the
proposed system so we can look to add
something in and if if during debate you
want to um talk to the most appropriate
statistics and data that could inform a
local calculation of housing need um
then we could look to add that into the
response um but as things stand
questions 1 to 7 are framed to um to
address the questions that have been
asked and particularly to um challenge
the use of affordability data rather
than propose an
alternative thank you councilor War boy
happy I'm just conscious that we stay on
track for actually questioning the
recommendation
um otherwise we'd pull this document
apart be here all night um and we've got
a working group that deals with that yes
thank you chair thank you thank you
thank you that's useful okay uh moving
on then to councelor Fleming
please yes thank you thank you very much
um I I I'll be brief but I really did
want to make a comment um on on this
proposal and our response to it while I
have the opportunity um just listening
in to the
questioning um I just would like to
mention that um Council Fleming so have
you got a question no I don't have a
question I've got a comment that I would
like no then we'll wait for debate
please so unless you got a question I
thought we were in we were allowed to go
into debate we're in questions okay I
beg your pardon okay councelor phield
please sorry to return just question
13 um there's an extensive analysis of
discounts against median and lower
quarti house prices it will be my
assumption that a first house is likely
to be a lower quartile house I wonder
what the relevance of analyzed median
house house prices
is did you say question 13 that's
question 13 in the consultation document
yes there's an extensive table of house
prices and uh discount levels and salary
levels all good stuff but I say it seems
to be an
analyzing in in in a way that's odd and
I was just
questioning why are we looking at
starter home first homes sorry being
median priced homes rather than being
lower quartile priced homes for
instance uh on on the view that if we're
wrong in our assumptions it destroys our
case I really do wish I could answer you
councelor field but um it's far too
technical for my go to assistant
director
please I'm I'm happy to try here and I
think this picks up this picks up the
point around um there not being a
limitation on the size of dwelling um so
for example it could be median because
the first time buyer may want to be
looking at a larger house um a four or
five bedroom dwelling is likely to fall
into that median bracket rather than the
lower quartile bracket and there is no
limitation on the size of dwellings that
would be appropriate for first
homes thank you um counselor Fleming
still got hand up have you got another
question
please
no okay now we'll moveing to debate so
again please keep the debate to your
three minutes you can speak once and
please let's focus on the
recommendations so straight away um
councelor Stringer
please um thank thank you chair uh I
don't know if you can see me I can't see
what's going on on this screen at the
moment anyway right yeah planning um
yeah this document is is really
difficult uh purely because of
it it it's written in a particular way
as these government documents are and it
makes several assumptions and it makes
several assumptions that that that that
frankly really ought not to be made with
the amount of advice that government has
at its
fingertips uh I'm long enough in the
tooth to have uh been here when we
altered our H4 uh I was at all the days
of the inquiry to argue that we altered
H4 and the reason we needed to alter H4
is because had a threshold for
affordable housing set at 25 and guess
what we kept getting planning
applications for 24 houses miraculously
just dipping under that bar uh what why
the government can't look at their data
and spot that we needed to change that
and so did every other authority uh I
don't know I think the most important
assumption that it makes is that
applying for outline planning permission
is done from the will of the applic app
an because they want to build houses if
you actually ask most of those
applicants often it's a company called
gladman uh they've never built a house
in their life they're in the business of
increasing land values and that's mostly
what people applying for outline
Planning Commission are going to
do uh and and the fact they haven't
spotted that is going to make this
really difficult in terms of housing
delivery which is the important thing
as that the government is in claiming it
wishes to increase uh and in fact if
we're not careful uh that we need to be
you know strong in our response that
that what we might end up having is
actually we have a dip in housing
delivery because the net result of low
the threshold if if I was a if I was a
developer now sitting on a permission
for 50 homes or 40 homes or 20 homes uh
that I've got a permission right now I
would now be reapplying under this new
Reg regime to get rid of the affordable
quota that I've now got to do and thus
increase my land value so I think it's
very important that we have a strong
message back to whoever wrote this
document that they really are not
looking at history as well as also
looking at the evidence that they surely
must have um so I think I say I'm I'm
I'm thankful that the proposer and
second of the Motions allowing uh extra
input into this uh after today's vote
uh and and thank you for that and thank
you for being part of the original team
that looked at our response it it was
actually very consensual what we got to
there but often after you have these you
distill it in your mind and I've been
distilling in our mind what we said and
looked at the documents even further and
I have to say it really is not a
brilliant document uh to use as
councelor field mentioned the snapshot
they're taken of the affordability ratio
is today and 10 years ago strer that's
that's three minutes sorry my last
sentence just to make the point 10 years
ago every British brick Factory was
closed because we were just gone through
the housing crash of 2008 so to use just
two snapshots is really not a good idea
and we need to speak that truth under
power thank you chair thank you some
good points there thank you and well
raised uh let's move on to Helen geek uh
sorry counselor geek now
please um thank you chair I hope I've
turned all my buttons on off I'll just
lower my hand um I say firstly can I
welcome um the detailed and the very
well judged response from the offices
and from the members of the working
group I just want to thank for all the
hard work and expertise they put into it
um I I am still interested in question
three the affordability ratio and I
think we could beef this up even further
because we've said that the ratio used
is the wrong one because it doesn't take
into account those who live in mids
suffk but work elsewhere where earnings
are higher we've also pointed out that
you almost always need to buy a mortgage
when you buy a home so the availability
and the prices of mortgages needs to be
sorted out at the same time as the
availability and the prices of houses
and we've also commented on the lein
review house builders ensure that
completions are slow they want to keep
prices high and they don't won't stand
for prices being brought down but there
is another reason that the affordability
ratio doesn't work and this is that most
houses are bought and sold secondhand so
it's a very different Market to anything
else you normally buy like potatoes or
trousers or whatever you're not you're
not buying new all the time the number
of new houses is absolutely tiny
compared to the secondhand stock in
babber and mids suffk new homes make up
less than
1.5% of the housing stock each year
their supply will never can never be
enough to bring down housing prices so
there's literally no point in applying
an affordability ratio I expect other
members can think of many other reasons
the affordability ratio simply will not
work to make houses more affordable the
only effect it will have is to make our
5year housing land Supply much more more
difficult to achieve so um so I think as
well as saying no to question three
because the entire premise of the
affordability ratio is misguided we
ought to stick that extra answer on as
well um and and that'll match better our
answers to questions four and
five thank you for your comments well
received and just a reminder to
everybody don't forget you know it's not
it's not just tonight you can take your
comments and your views and your
concerns or your good ideas to that
cross party working group um so don't
forget that once you've left this actual
meeting so let's go on to councelor
Fleming
please well thank you very much um thank
you um chairman um I too would like to
recognize the hard work of um Tom Barker
and his team and the working group in um
preparing a response with to both this
and the future white paper consultation
um I fully understand that that's an
awful lot of work an unprecedented
amount of work so thank you um I would
like to express my concerns however
about both of the consultations that
we're looking at and they are clearly
linked one to the other the latter that
is the changes in planning system being
the the delivery vehicle for the former
which is the white
paper um I I believe that these papers
were both received before the covid
outbreak and they do not take into
account the recent programs intended to
strengthen protections for biodiversity
in the
environment and the changing
post-pandemic demographics that we're
likely to
see um without going into further detail
about the actual
proposals um I believe that we need to
send a very strong and clear message to
mclg listen to the responses that they
are receiving and to think again about
the context in which planning reform
should operate since these are profound
changes that
are that that are being taken and they
will affect the future shape of our
communities and our country um so that
that that is my comment but I also want
to comment on the um note in paragraph
11 7.1 about the
environmental implications because I
cannot say I completely
agree that there are no the
environmental implications can be
mitigated by the proposed changes that
that is in our paper under the present
structures that we're seeing before us
so I just don't believe that's possible
thank you very much thank you councilor
Fleming um let's move on now to uh
councilor warboy
please thank you chair um yeah I think
I'll I turn my question into a bit more
of a statement I think this as as
councilor Fleming has pointed out the
the two papers
are are linked and one leads on to the
other it is a a move as it says in the
the second white paper about a data
approach to planning machine readable
forms fewer
documentations and I think
reducing the calculation of of housing
requirements just
numerically by looking at the the cost
of housing is is a is perhaps a starting
point but it it's by no means the only
picture it is incredibly important to
take into account I think the
Democratic um sorry not de demographic
pressures on on housing needs um and ex
for example I I was supposed to have try
and get one
uh the um currently about one in five
people living in sufferer age 65 and
over over the next 20 years this is
forecast to change with one in three one
in three suffk residents being age 65
and over
compared to one in for for England uh
and looking at the figures and burying
it down to MIT SE msuk is ahead of the
game msuk has got a a relatively older
population within suffk as a whole now
that should be an important factor in
determin what sort of houses are being
built and the number of
houses it's and it's not necess Sly
price and older people may well be able
to afford expensive houses but it's very
much about the type of houses and the
number of houses that to be needed um so
I I think my point is that
our response to this paper must be that
it it's very important to have a very
bespoke solution to housing needs and
it's not enough to rely on a one siiz
fits-all algorithm that will work
nationally it's it can only be a
starting
point C W boys thank you and I think uh
some of your important points there will
be picked up by the working group uh
this is where they belong um I'm going
to now move to counselor field
please uh you keep referring to the
working group which which I'm on but
it's not going to see this document
again
it's going to councelor burn with
councelor Stringer and one other in in
toe uh so I would just point out you
know absolutely my view is we must make
a really robust response to to this a
and we need to make the points that are
made in your document here about the
affordability ratio you might even add
something into the algorithm that
represent that
reflected the age distribution in in the
population would be a sensible thing we
clearly can't debate all those things
tonight my fear is that this document
needs a very
careful uh should we call it quality
assurance
audit I'm sure councilors burn and
Stringer and Tom will do that but it
needs reading very carefully making sure
that it's expressing in clear English
what we clear want to achieve at the
moment my view is although it's an
excellent effort it does show signs of
being written in an awful
hurry um and one point I would make in
that is I made the points about
volatility of of the estimates and
things before but the other thing that
does seem questionable to me as a
government principle is that they're
seeking to subsidize first homes and I
have to say that appears to be
irrespective of the wealth of the
purchaser um I think I did invoke at a
previous meeting some relations of mine
who'd love a cheap house but don't
deserve one um I think you we have to be
very careful there and our analysis that
we put in here to my mind rather
supports government sties to people who
clearly don't need them and I'll rest my
case
there thank you councelor Phil and thank
you for the correction which is as
always warmly received um I can now see
councelor Austin
please
um Council Rustin we're having problems
with your microphone I think if you
could just try again okay is that better
yeah you're there thank you the new um
responses there were just three that I
thought I would really highlight um
question five about protecting areas of
outstanding natural beauty which I think
is extraordinarily important um and the
other were questions 16 and 17 about
agreeing to the objection of remaining
the site and site size and threshold and
I think there are issues there which are
extremely
important um and really should be made
made extremely clear um am I allowed to
comment now on the actual white paper
chairman uh no we're gonna go on to the
white paper so no not yet thank you okay
good try then
yeah is that is that your um is that
your comment thank
you okay uh as far as hands go up now um
I've got coun Stringer but you've
already had your debates and your three
minutes in fact just over so you can't
speak again in debate I'm afraid I
notice your hands now gone down thank
you yes I thought it was down CH all
right no no problem I didn't think yeah
I didn't think you try it on twice uh
and councelor oton you're now complete I
I get so let's go to councelor Wellen
please thank you chair I I want to talk
about first homes the whole thrust of
first home seems to be to encourage
planning applications which secure an
increase in land values and profits for
development compan companies it doesn't
help residents find their real first
home I believe there needs to be further
incentives to build homes for social
rent uh the these are for many the first
real and and sometimes the only
home when I was young people were very
proud of their Council houses a council
home was what parents with young
families aspired to now couples feel the
need to buy their own home and some do
so when they can't really afford it
often using the bank of mom and
dad house prices could stabilize if new
homes for social rent were made readily
available the private rental sector has
a role to play but unless more homes are
available at Social rent nothing will
change private rents will remain too
high too high for many to afford and
house prices will continue to rise
incentives to buy should not increase
and that that includes um the threshold
for affordable homes within
development
um and um fund should be made available
to expand the social rental sector with
passive house or similar low energy
construction as the norm precisely where
that would fit in to the to the response
I'm not sure but I think something under
the heading of first homes needs to
point out that real first homes
lowercase first home homes are often the
only homes that people will ever H will
ever ever own and for many it's a
council house and that's what they
should be aspiring
to thank you for your comments um
councelor B uh yeah that's nobody else
so councelor burn um would you like to
sum up please well yeah I'll I'll try
but I mean it it it it seems to me that
the the the various headings in this uh
in this p in this particular paper uh
changes to the current planning system
beg um a lot of questions which have
been asked this evening and and and
answers
attempted but they are not the questions
that are asked in the consultation so
it's extremely difficult yes there may
be opportunities for um ex explaining we
feel a better system would be but it's
we we were not asked in the beginning to
devise a A system that would work for
mids suffk we were asked to respond to
the questions that were asked in this
particular paper now they may well be
leading questions they may well be uh
bringing out answers that are inadequate
so far as mids is concerned and I do do
take a lot of the points that have been
made this evening um yes councilor field
was correct there is no working group
scheduled to meet again to discuss any
of these and you must also remember that
time is now very short we have to uh
return this consultation response by the
1st of October um but anyway uh it's
been an interesting um it's been an
interesting uh discussion and debate uh
an interesting set of questions uh we
can obviously look back on the recording
and and and pick out the detail which we
definitely will do uh but that's about
as much summing up as I'm I'm able to do
all I'd like to do and now is to is to
thank um the members of the working
group councilors Guthrie uh Stringer and
field as well as the colleagues from
babber who attended the Roundtable
discussions informed this response I'd
also like to thank the team that put the
response together because as you can see
it has been a very difficult task it has
been a very laborious task now we'll do
what we can to Beef It Up the way you'd
like it beefed up um I'm perfectly happy
to do that so uh that's about as far as
I go I just uh like to repeat my um
request that you support this
recommendation thank
you thank you and um it's been some time
actually since we heard the amendment to
the recommendation so Council eurn would
you just like to cover that Amendment
again please so that we're all clear
thank you um thank you very much chair
it was just to include the after the
words um Cabinet member for planning to
include the um opposition spokesperson
for planning thank you chair thank you
that's clear so therefore we will be
taking a vote on the recommendations
with the amendment as um amended by
Council eburn so the corporate manager
governance and Civic officer will now
take a roll call
vote thank you chair if councilors could
reply with for against or abstention
thank you counc Morrison four councelor
Brewster four councelor burn four
councelor Carter has left the meeting
councelor Casten for councelor
eurn or counc
epong four councelor field four
councelor flatman four councelor Fleming
four councelor geek four councelor gold
po councelor Guthrie po councelor
hadingham
four councelor Hicks four councelor
Humphries four councelor Manel four
councelor maton four councelor melon
four councelor mayor for councelor moley
four councelor Müller four councelor
Norris four councelor utton four
councelor parmor is left the meeting
councelor Phillips for councelor
Pratt four councelor Richardson four
councelor scarf four councelor Stringer
four councelor Turner four councelor War
boys for councelor wellam for councelor
Whitehead for
N Miss that is carried we now move on to
item 20 which is the white paper
planning for the future um I'd like to
invite councelor burn back please to
introduce this item and move the tabled
recommendation councelor burn right
thank you very much chairman um this is
more widely known than the previous
planning consultation on this evening's
agenda it's the one on the government's
new planning white paper which is called
planning for the future and this
consultation closes on the 29th of next
month the white paper proposes
significant reforms of the planning
system with the declared intention of
streamlining and modernizing the
planning process bringing a new Focus to
design and
sustainability improving the system of
developer contributions to
infrastructure and ensuring more Landers
available for development where it is
needed in responding to the consultation
there are 26 questions to be
answered uh this item is on the agenda
today without an accompanying
report the white paper is a significant
document and it was not possible to go
through the same approach as the
previous consultation within the time
available prior to this
meeting
um we have almost all the next month in
which to prepare our response but we
don't have another council meeting to
bring it to so I proposing to delegate
submission of our response to the
assistant director for sustainable
communities having prepared it in
consultation with the cabinet member for
planning and the same cross-party group
that considered the changes to the
current planning system
consultation uh the glossy version of
plan for the future is 84 pages long uh
but there is a Texton version of it of
just over 60 Pages for those who are not
familiar with its content I'll briefly
mention some some of the headline
proposals they suggest new stripped back
local plans with all land zoned for
either growth renewal or protection they
propose the end of section 106
contributions with all contributions
being via VIA a uh that's developer
contributions being via a levy similar
to our existing sill but it won't be
called a community infrastructure Levy
it will just be an infrastructure
Levy uh there are topown housing targets
proposed in similar way to the proposals
in the consultation on the current
system uh a new body is proposed with
the role of supporting local authorities
in the creation of local design codes
and each local Authority will be
expected to employ an officer in the new
statutory role of chief officer for
design and placemaking to oversee
quality local design codes must have a
community input to be
valid also more per permitted
development is proposed by introducing
new more extensive permitted development
rights I welcome come any questions or
debate to help inform the proposed
Roundtable discussions to agree the
response so just to uh remind you I'm
proposing our responses formulated via
the same cross party group as the
previous one uh that's the uh the one
that formulated the responses to changes
to the current planning system thank
you thank you do we have a second for
the proposal
please yes happy to Second Kathy G counc
gri thank you very much okay so we're
now moving into questions and debat
councelors can ask questions but only
debate the tabled recommendation so
we're not debating the white paper we're
debating the recommendation I hope
that's clear so again please keep your
questions on track um nice and short and
we'll give you a nice and short answer
I'm
sure so first question then uh councelor
War
boys thank you
uh I is it will it be possible to
submit uh one's own uh responses to the
round table discussion and is there a
timetable for doing
so or will there be a Tim table for
doing
so uh well the answer to that is be
happy to to receive any the I'm sure the
the group will be happy to receive any
any comment or suggestions from any
member uh timetable for doing so is Asap
isn't it because um we will have to
schedule
meetings uh and we will have to leave
sufficient time for the officers to uh
do do the final response um but yes
please do and there's nothing of course
to stop you as individuals responding to
it
directly thank
you councelor utton please
I think this is extremely important
paper um and I think it's really
important that all members have some
input into that um I'd also like to um
ask whether or not the council will be
actually looking at what the local
government Association responses will be
um because obviously this affects
councils across the whole country um and
I think it would be useful for the
council and I believe even um the chair
of the local government housing board um
is a conservative and H and and has his
own reservations about some of the um
proposals from government so will the
council be looking at how the LGA will
be
responding I I think we'll be looking at
how all sorts of people are are going to
on all sorts of of organizations are
responding yes definitely the LGA and
there are there are other webinars and
and and uh various events have been
arranged by um other groups and other
organizations that uh I certainly will
be taking note of and I'm sure my B
counterpart will be too and I'm sure the
officers concerned will will be taking
note of those so yes
uh we definitely will
be thank you and uh moving on to
councelor eburn
please thank you very much chair um I've
I've got several questions which I
suspect won't won't be able to um be
answered um however um I was wondering
if we could have the date of the um
group The working group meeting as soon
as possible because then obviously it's
getting late and I guess
not that we're not all not at home but I
think I I guess people want to rest um
it's been a long meeting and um if we
had the date we could therefore know
when we can input into any of the
members of that working group um but two
particular questions I've got are there
seems to be a kind of contradiction
really
in between them saying in the
consultation that the support for
neighborhood plans yet um a concern
about kind of um local government and
particularly counselors as such as
ourselves getting too involved so that
seems to be a bit of a contradiction and
secondly I'm concerned about these the
zoning that the zoning that they mention
about um protected areas they seem to
only be talking about Green Belt and
obviously we don't have any green belt
in this area and just in response to
councilor Fleming um this um cons
consultation paper is based Bas on one
by the policy exchange and it's the same
author and the policy exchange paper was
published on the 27th of January so yes
it was it was created in in embryo as it
were be well before covid um but I'm
concerned about the contradictions that
I've mentioned and I don't think I can
get an answer tonight but I would just
like to raise them thank you chair well
raised and I'm sure that councilor bur
will come back to you and so so Tom with
the answers to those questions if you're
satisfied with that okay um next
question then from councelor Geek
please thank you very much thank you
very much chair um I've got another
quite short unanswerable question I'm
afraid can I ask what problem this white
paper is trying to solve now I know
thanks to the Red Fern review which
isn't mentioned so much that we don't
have a chronic shortage of houses we've
actually got a housing Surplus believe
it or not nobody believes that but it's
true these houses are there with the
wrong types they're usually in the wrong
place places and crucially they're being
used for the wrong things so we might
have a chronic shortage of housing
because houses are being used as
Investments rather than as homes but we
don't have a shortage of
houses I also know as we all know and
it's constantly said that we don't have
a shortage of planning permissions so it
can't be trying to fix that we all know
from the lein report that we need a
system that ensures those permissions
are built we don't need to just get more
and more of them I hate to interrupt
because it's rude however it's almost
debate so one a question thank you um
and if it's trying to solve the housing
crisis the only way to do that is surely
for councils including our own and this
is what we should say shouldn't we uh to
buy up those hoarded houses get them out
for social rent which incidentally
enables that frustrated firsttime buyer
to save up for their deposit a crucial
thing thank you good points well done
stick to
questions but yeah Fair Point okay um
counc War boys uh you still got your
hand up are you have you another
question no okay fantastic uh we will
move into debate now everybody um sorry
counselor Phil before we do so do you
have another
question no I had a
debate okay no problem we're gonna move
straight to that stay online um so don't
forget the debate can only be around the
tabled recommendations is everybody
happy with that good right councelor
field right happy with what councelor
bur has
suggested the working party needs to get
on with this we obviously need to
respond to this document and we've heard
some various opinions about it there
there certainly some problems I
personally think we also have a a major
issue which is how would we seek to map
this onto our own situation I um you
know I'm quite happy for my Village to
be defined as an area for protection uh
some of you others might not agree um
how do we make that mapping seems to me
to be a second a second liar of this
problem the first one is clearly to go
through this document and answer all the
questions and I personally have only
read half of it so far so I think I
should stop making comments
there thank you perhaps I should say we
need a time scale what what have we got
5 weeks is it that's very short we need
to make sure the meetings
are are scheduled rapidly and that we
have some very clear ideas of what we're
trying to achieve in each
meeting thank you okay um next one
councelor Stringer please yeah those
that are going to be involved in the uh
in the response to this on the working
party are going to probably need to go
to bed quite soon to actually get the
energy to be a to go through what will
be some some meetings so I won't bang on
too long I think uh councelor uh
councilor Fleming raised an issue that
we probably ought to try and build into
our response and we it mustn't be War
and Peace but it sometimes it feels like
we are actually at war with the
government on this um we what's the
post-pandemic world going to look like
because this document's clearly written
before that uh and there could well be a
glut of empty town and City Center
properties uh that are used for
commercial purposes at the moment that
could actually repopulate our towns with
with very affordable dwellings for
people uh and I think we need to be
saying that quite quite you quite large
and quite proud because I think that
could actually help crack that nut uh
rather than use you
know algorithms that are prove to be not
very efficient thank you chair yeah very
good okay and uh councelor uton
please uh yeah I mean I don't want to
hang around much longer I'm sure most
people don't um but I do think that we
need to make sure that the houses that
are being proposed and and it needs to
have a locally LED planning system but
it must be to include and support
infrastructure schools and promote
Greener and more active tra um travel
and to take into account the C the this
councils and the government's um climate
emergency I think those are absolutely
essential and I fear has been said um
this was drawn up way back in January
and even the government I don't think
had declared a climate emergency then um
and I feel that we must not allow that
to just slip through okay and again if
you could just stick to the
recommendation because that's all we
should actually be debating but I do get
your points okay well made okay um that
is everybody so uh councelor burn I see
you're dying to sum up really quickly um
over to you I am yes yes thank you for
the uh your Christmas wish list um
councelor Aon
uh I I agree that if we I mean it's it's
well recognized that um uh these two
particular papers givers uh
consultations um give us a a poor deal
in our area so uh if we can in some way
try and skew it back to or skew it in
our direction we will of course try to
do so so far as the uh the speed we've
got to work that's obvious uh Council
field you're quite right um first thing
tomorrow we're going to have to get on
to trying to uh organize the first
meeting of the working group and um yes
we need however many meetings it takes
takes we've got to be pretty sure that
we're focused on what we're doing so uh
and I'm very happy to to uh proceed in
in that way so thank you very much for
all the suggestions and comments this
evening um I found it very helpful uh
and I'm sure that uh Tom listening in uh
and contributing um has also found it
helpful and informing and we'll go away
and and uh act on it thank you thank you
councilor burn um so the corporate
manager governance and Civic officer
will now take a roll call
vote thank you chair so if members can
reply with for against or abstain
councelor
Morrison sorry can you just um clarify
what exactly we're voting on so um yes
we are voting to a grant Authority
delegated authority to the assistant
director for sustainable Community to
submit a response to the the
consultation on the white paper planning
for the future on behalf of the council
this is in consultation with the cabinet
member for planning and the same
cross-party group that considered the
changes to the current planning system
consultation good four okay four thank
you councelor Brewster four councelor
burn four councelor Carter has left the
meeting councelor Casten four councelor
e burn four counc epon four councelor
field four councelor flatman four
councelor Fleming four councelor geek
four councelor gold four councelor
Guthrie four councelor hadingham
four councelor Hicks four councilor
Humphries
four councilor Mansel four councelor
Matson four councelor melon four
councilor mayor four councelor moley
four councelor Müller four councelor
Norris four councelor utton four
councelor pmore has left the meeting
councelor Phillips four councelor Pratt
four councelor Richardson four councelor
scarf four councelor Stringer four
councelor Turner four councelor War boys
four councelor wellam four councelor
Whitehead
four thank
you that is carried and I'd like to
thank you all um for for staying with it
really and the valuable contribution for
tonight's meeting is really appreciated
as is the support that we've been given
by the officers to keep this thing on
track throughout the night uh a real
huge thank you um please remember stay
safe download the NHS track and trace
app use it you know it's important and
um and thank you for testing me tonight
it's been really interesting I've
learned a heck of a lot about being a
chair and uh and hopefully I'll learn
more as we go forward with your support
um the date of the next meeting is
Thursday the 26th of November at 5:30
p.m. I look forward to seeing you all
there good
night